Good morning. Good morning listener. Good morning listener. It's crowded on the 605 and the weather looks balmy. It's bumper to bumper. Well what's it look like up in the copter? We're all going to be here having yourself a great weekend. It's an all new smart list. Jason why do you look like you're skiing? You look like you're skiing clothes. Well because I just dropped the kids off at school. It's cold out. You know we're going to have temperatures below freezing here in Southern California this week. I heard that. That's not below freezing, but it's going to be cold, right? Yeah, below freezing in parts of our great city. Wow. That's what they say. I can't wait for that. The LA Times says, I don't know if you guys read that, you Philistines. You know, first of all,
早上好。早上好，听众朋友们。早上好，听众朋友们。605号公路现在很拥堵，天气看起来很温和。车子一辆挨着一辆。那么直升机上看起来怎么样？我们大家都会在这里度过一个愉快的周末。这是一个全新的智能列表。杰森，你为什么看起来像是在滑雪？你穿得像是在滑雪。因为我刚把孩子们送到学校。外面很冷。你知道，这周南加州的气温会降到冰点以下。我听说了。那不是冰点以下，但会很冷，对吧？是的，在我们伟大城市的部分地区会降到冰点以下。哇。他们是这么说的。我等不及了。《洛杉矶时报》说，我不知道你们有没有读过，你们这些庸俗的人。你知道，首先，
I argue with Scotty all the time. He's like, I like when it gets super cold here because he's like, I hate it. Where's the sun? It's like the sun's going to happen for eight months and it's going to be 110 degrees. So keep me enjoyed like the cool. No, I agree with you. Nothing worse than sweating on Christmas Day here in Los Angeles. Hey, Jay, did you get, you know, plus you get to accessorize and when it's cold, like the little hat you guys just shamed me on. You didn't shame. You were just wondering, you just looked like you were taking a break from the slopes. You just had a good run. Looks like you had a couple good runs and you came in to warm up. Yeah. Hey, Jay, did you know, is Jason's birthday a while ago as we all know back in January? Did you, and I finally
我总是和斯科蒂争论。他总是说，我喜欢这里变得超级冷，因为他说，我讨厌这样。太阳去哪了？好像太阳八个月都会出来，而且气温会达到110度。所以让我享受凉爽吧。不，我同意你的看法。在洛杉矶，圣诞节那天出汗是最糟糕的事情。嘿，杰，你有没有，你知道，而且你还可以搭配饰品，当天气冷的时候，就像你们刚才嘲笑我的那顶小帽子。你们没有嘲笑。你们只是觉得奇怪，你看起来就像刚从滑雪场休息回来。你刚才滑得很开心。看起来你滑了几趟好雪，然后进来暖和一下。是的。嘿，杰，你知道吗，杰森的生日是不是很久以前，就像我们都知道的那样，在去年一月？你，我终于
sent you my present late. You got my present. So, you know, I often complain and I'm always jealous of how much money Will has and then also how much he spends on himself. And particularly in fashion, he's fond of Laura Piano or Piana, whatever it is. Laura Piano, but that's okay. Does anyone know who that is? Well, it's really expensive. And so he sends over two boxes of this. Oh, it was in those boxes. That's right. And then beautiful brown sort of that. And I think, oh, well, this makes sense because he feels bad about flaking on my birthday dinner that you guys went to. Yeah, back on your birthday because I was sick. Claims to be sick for because he still doesn't look or sound sick. And then he flaked again on a golf yesterday morning with daddy's because he still
迟到了才给你寄礼物。你收到我的礼物了。所以，你知道，我经常抱怨，我总是嫉妒威尔有多少钱，以及他花在自己身上有多少钱。特别是在时尚方面，他喜欢劳罗·皮亚纳（Loro Piana）或者别的什么。劳罗·皮亚纳，不过没关系。有人知道那是谁吗？嗯，它真的很贵。所以他寄来了两盒这个。哦，原来是在那些盒子里。没错。还有漂亮的棕色那种。我想，哦，好吧，这说得通，因为他对自己没去参加你们去的我的生日晚宴感到内疚。是的，在你生日那天，因为我病了。声称生病了，因为他看起来或听起来一点都不像生病了。然后他昨天早上又因为高尔夫球放了达迪斯（Daddys）的鸽子，因为他还是
doesn't look sick or sick. And by the way, it should be noted also, I had a year ago for Christmas, gave you something from Laura Piano. Yeah. So let's just start with the nice part, which is, you know, what was it? Was it sweater? Sweater. Thanks. Yeah. Thanks. Probably returned it. Anyway, so I open up these things and what's in the box, Sean, three tubes of Pringles. Yeah. And one box. And then in the other one, there's just shit from his terrible pantry, which is nothing but Oreos and Fritos. And you know what? And he said to me when he said he was going to send it to you that he goes, and now it's fucking stuck in your house. And now you're going to have to eat. Oh, no, well, it's already out, it's already in the trash. But here's the
看起来不像生病了。顺便说一句，应该指出的是，一年前的圣诞节，我给了你一件劳罗·皮亚纳的东西。是的。所以让我们从好的部分开始，那就是，你知道，那是什么？是毛衣吗？毛衣。谢谢。是的。谢谢。可能退货了。不管怎样，我打开这些东西，盒子里装的是什么，肖恩，三筒品客薯片。是的。还有一个盒子。另一个盒子里只有他那糟糕储藏室里的垃圾，除了奥利奥和多力多滋什么都没有。你知道吗？当他说要寄给你的时候，他说，现在它该死地卡在你家里了。现在你得把它吃掉。哦，不，好吧，它已经拿出来了，已经在垃圾桶里了。但问题是，
problem. I trojan-horst it. I trojan-horst it into the house. This is what you didn't factor in, is that you got a grin out of me, but you got rage and fire from my wife, who, you know, is all about, you know, well, listen, if we got a gift for him, he's got, he's got, better get you a nice gift, you know? And then, and so she saw the box, she's like, oh, this is so good, good for him. You know what? He's good for him. And then she saw this. Just rerouted to my house. You pissed off, you poked the bear. But you know what? She sounds like she needs to lighten up first of all. Well, she's talking, you're talking my language. So, you know, right off the bat,
我把它像特洛伊木马一样弄进屋里了。这是你没考虑到的，你让我笑了，但我却遭到了我妻子的愤怒和火气，你知道，她总是，你知道，好吧，听着，如果我们给他准备了礼物，他得，他得，最好给你准备一份好礼物，你知道吗？然后，她看到了盒子，她说，哦，这太好了，对他好。你知道吗？他对他好。然后她看到了这个。直接转寄到我家了。你惹毛了，你捅了马蜂窝。但你知道吗？首先，她听起来需要放轻松点。好吧，她在说，你在说我的语言。所以，你知道，一开始，
she needs to lighten up. I did get you a nice gift. I got her real nice gift for her birthday. Well, we're not talking, hang on. Well, back up to me. Where is my nice gift? It's, it's, dude. It was mine. It was mine. It's from both of us. Oh, I'm looking at it. Got it. Oh, thanks. No, it's the gift of gab. I don't need gifts actually. I'm just, I'm just, you expressly said, you expressly said, you got me a beautiful, beautiful spa day. Right. Yeah. And you know, I like to keep my myself well massaged and hydrated. Does it remind you of being on that school bus just cruising along LA city streets and giving each other massage, massage bus. That guy's got to be in jail by now. Right. The guy who ran that
她需要放轻松点。我确实给了你一份好礼物。我给她生日准备了一份非常好的礼物。好吧，我们不是在说，等等。好吧，回到我这里。我的好礼物在哪里？它是，它是，伙计。那是我的。那是我们俩送的。哦，我正在看它。收到了。哦，谢谢。不，这是口才的礼物。其实我不需要礼物。我只是，我只是，你明确说过，你明确说过，你给了我一个美丽、美丽的温泉日。对吧。是的。而且你知道，我喜欢让自己保持良好的按摩和水分。这让你想起坐在那辆沿着洛杉矶城市街道行驶的校车上，互相按摩，按摩巴士吗？那家伙现在肯定在监狱里了。对吧。那个经营那个
who ran the kitty massage bus. Yeah. I think that they might've taken a look at him. The guy who started the experimental school was the first red flag. Yeah. Hey, by the way, we should be pointing out how excited are you guys about today is the big March day opening. Yes. It is. I think it's called merch day. Is it called merch day officially? It's called merch day. We should call it merch madness. Oh, God. That's so good. Merch madness is great. Come on. Merch madness is happening at, at, at the Wondery shop. Right. What is it? W, W, W. Do we still say www.wondryshop.com slash W, W, W dot. I think nowadays you can just, you can just click the address thing.
经营那个儿童按摩巴士的家伙。是的。我想他们可能已经调查他了。那个创办实验学校的家伙是第一个危险信号。是的。嘿，顺便说一句，我们应该指出你们对今天的商品大促销有多兴奋。是的。我想它叫商品日。它正式叫商品日吗？它叫商品日。我们应该叫它商品狂欢。哦，天哪。那太棒了。商品狂欢太棒了。来吧。商品狂欢正在Wondery商店进行，对吧。是什么？W，W，W。我们还在说www.wondryshop.com斜杠，W，W，W点。我想现在你只需要，你只需要点击地址栏。
You just wondryshop.com slash smartlist. Wondry shop. Wondry shop. Wait, wait. Say it one more time. What is it? Wondry shop.com slash smartlist. So that would be W-O-N-D-E-R-Y-S-H-O-P. Yep. Dot com slash slash smartlist. And that's where you get all like, what do you get? You get t-shirts, phone cases, water bottles. By the way, we have so many. Look at this. We got this. Look at, look at my new, look at the new phone. You can't use it on, we can't use any of this stuff. Imagine walking around with a smartlist phone case. I wear a smartlist t-shirt all the time. You can't do that. Why? Because you're on smartlist. But let me tell you, nobody who's going to see him, he's in the living room and then the TV room. The guys at Chin Chin will say, hey, cheesebag,
你只需要wondryshop.com斜杠smartlist。Wondery商店。Wondery商店。等等，等等。再说一遍。是什么？Wondryshop.com斜杠smartlist。所以那是W-O-N-D-E-R-Y-S-H-O-P。没错。点com斜杠斜杠smartlist。那就是你得到所有像，你得到什么？你得到T恤，手机壳，水瓶。顺便说一句，我们有很多。看这个。我们有这个。看，看我的新，看新手机。你不能用它，我们不能用这些东西。想象一下拿着一个smartlist手机壳走来走去。我一直穿着smartlist T恤。你不能那样做。为什么？因为你在smartlist节目里。但让我告诉你，没人会看到他，他在客厅，然后在电视室。Chin Chin的伙计们会说，嘿，奶酪包，
get out of here. And he just, he pulls outside of Chin Chin. He doesn't even go in. He honks three times. He has a special honk. And then they, and I raise my chair. I raise my chair so they can see the smartlist logo on my t-shirt. No, license plate friend that says smartlist. I'll put it on. I don't care. I don't care. He puts it on the hood of his car and he put it in backwards so people can see it in the rear views, you know, like an angel. But let me tell you something. I would buy this stuff. I've had nothing to do with this. It's the t-shirts are great. There's this pretty weird that we've got t-shirts and sweat water bottles and stickers and what's going on. You know what are the hats too? Because as a, the hats are very, the hats are great. They're super
滚出去。他只是，他把车停在Chin Chin外面。他甚至不进去。他按了三下喇叭。他有一个特殊的喇叭声。然后他们，我抬起我的椅子。我抬起我的椅子，这样他们就能看到我T恤上的smartlist标志。没有写着smartlist的车牌，朋友。我会把它装上的。我不在乎。我不在乎。他把它装在车盖上，而且装反了，这样人们可以在后视镜里看到它，你知道，就像一个天使。但让我告诉你一件事。我会买这些东西。我对此一无所知。T恤很棒。我们有T恤、汗水瓶、贴纸，这很奇怪，发生了什么事。你知道帽子也一样吗？因为作为，帽子非常，帽子很棒。它们超级
cool. But let me tell you something really quick about the blankets. So when we were talking about it, they called it a throw blanket. And I was like, I don't understand a throw blanket. Like it's, a throw blanket is like the size of just one foot. Like it's made one foot warm. So it's like, can we do like full blankets? And we have full sized blankets that are sure for blankets are super. They cover your whole body. You know what I like about that? Those blankets is that they're quite, that they've got a little bit of weight to them. They're not weighted, but they're nice and big. And they're, they're on one side, it's that sort of softy, like, like, softy fleece. And the other side of what is it? What is that on the other side? It's like a, I don't know. It's another
酷。但让我快速告诉你关于毯子的事。所以当我们谈论它时，他们称之为投掷毯。我就想，我不明白投掷毯。就像它，投掷毯就像只有一只脚那么大。就像它让人一只脚暖和。所以就像，我们能做全尺寸毯子吗？我们有全尺寸毯子，它们确实是毯子，超级。它们覆盖你的全身。你知道我喜欢那些毯子什么吗？它们相当，它们有一点重量。它们不是加重毯，但它们又大又好。而且它们，它们的一面是那种柔软的，像，像，柔软的羊毛。另一面是什么？另一面是什么？它就像一个，我不知道。它是另一个
soft something. Yeah. It's a real soft. Anyway, the merch, it's merch madness. It's merch madness. It's www.wonderishshop.com slash smartly. So you'll find some great stuff. Please enjoy. Okay. Shall, shall we? Let's, let's, let's do it guys, because you're gonna want to talk to this fella for, this could be a double session. Tuck in. Okay. Now we've had some pretty fancy folks on here as guests and even a few that are the undisputed best at what they do. Goats. Sean, do you know what that acronym stands for? Yes. It's good all time around fun time. Pretty close. Greatest of all time. Our next guest is the goat of his field. And if you love sports, Sean, I know you do. This is going to be a treat. And if you don't love sports, sit tight because you're going
柔软的东西。是的。它真的很软。不管怎样，商品，这是商品狂欢。这是商品狂欢。这是www.wonderishshop.com斜杠smartly。所以你会找到一些很棒的东西。请享受。好的。我们，我们开始吧？让我们，让我们，让我们开始吧，伙计们，因为你们会想和这家伙谈谈，这可能是一次双重会议。准备好了。好的。现在我们这里有一些非常时髦的客人，甚至有几个是他们领域无可争议的最佳人选。山羊（GOAT）。肖恩，你知道这个缩写代表什么吗？是的。它是“全时段好时光”。很接近。史上最伟大（Greatest of All Time）。我们的下一位嘉宾是他领域的山羊。如果你热爱体育，肖恩，我知道你热爱。这会是一种享受。如果你不热爱体育，坐稳了，因为你
to love this man anyways. Got a voice you've heard your whole life, a friendly face that's been on your TV, your whole life, and a golf swing you don't need to see your whole life. He has eight Emmy awards. He's in the pro football hall of fame, the television hall of fame, the sports casters hall of fame. He's the only sportscaster to have called play by play for the championship series of all four major professional. Six super bowls, eight world series, two NBA finals, three Stanley cups. He's born in Brooklyn, started in Hawaii, and now joins us here on smart list. Folks, please welcome one of my favorite people, our national treasure, Mr. Will. Oh, my God. No way. Bring him in. No way. Yeah. This man, he just brings a smile to my face.
无论如何都会喜欢这个人。有一个你一生都听过的声音，一张你一生都在电视上看到的友好的脸，和一个你一生都不需要看到的挥杆动作。他获得了八项艾美奖。他进入了职业橄榄球名人堂、电视名人堂、体育解说员名人堂。他是唯一一位为所有四大职业联赛的冠军系列赛进行过逐场解说的体育解说员。六次超级碗，八次世界大赛，两次NBA总决赛，三次斯坦利杯。他出生在布鲁克林，在夏威夷起步，现在加入我们的smart list。各位，请欢迎我最喜欢的人之一，我们的国宝，威尔先生。哦，天哪。不会吧。让他进来。不会吧。是的。这个人，他只是让我脸上露出了笑容。
Same here. Hi, Al. Even my face. You know, Sean, you know, this is on one hand, a tremendous honor. I know it. When I go back and I look at the fact that you guys have done Spielberg. You've done Bono. You've done the president of the United States. You've done Clooney. You've done Bradley Cooper. You've done my buddy Joe Buck. I mean, the truth has to be told, guys. What took so long? So who got sick last night, and who am I coming out of the bullpen for? Couldn't make you deal, Al. We could not make you deal. Yeah. So, listener, so we do play some golf together. Oh, you and Al do? Oh, yeah. I've been threatening to pull him on this show for a while. And finally, our schedules collided because you are a little busy, Al. And let's talk a little
我也是，阿尔。甚至我的脸。你知道，肖恩，你知道，这一方面，是一个巨大的荣誉。我知道。当我回过头来看，你们做过斯皮尔伯格。你们做过波诺。你们做过美国总统。你们做过克鲁尼。你们做过布莱德利·库珀。你们做过我的好友乔·巴克。我的意思是，必须说实话，伙计们。花了这么久？那么昨晚谁生病了，我是从牛棚里出来替补谁的？没能和你做成交易，阿尔。我们没能和你做成交易。是的。所以，听众朋友们，我们确实一起打高尔夫球。哦，你和阿尔一起？哦，是的。我威胁要让他上这个节目已经有一段时间了。最后，我们的日程安排撞上了，因为你有点忙，阿尔。让我们谈谈
bit about that. How do you, I mean, you must not mind travel that much. Now, I know you're not, you're not, you're not humping it on a steamer. 36 J. Yeah. You're not in the back of the plane often, but still time zones and packing bags and leaving family and all that stuff. How do you do that all these years? You know, early on, I was so intent on, you know, doing, getting to the top of this business that I traveled a ton, didn't really think about the burden of traveling. You know, at a certain point, I think when you're young and you're going to new places, you're excited. And I'm not saying I'm not excited to go to Pittsburgh, but the first or second time I've been to Pittsburgh or was in Pittsburgh, it was fun because I like to get
那一点。你怎么，我的意思是，你一定不介意旅行那么多。现在，我知道你不是，你不是，你不是在轮船上辛苦跋涉。36 J。是的。你通常不在飞机后部，但时区、打包行李、离开家人等等，所有这些事情。这些年来你是怎么做到的？你知道，早些时候，我非常专注于，你知道，做到，达到这个行业的顶峰，所以我旅行了很多，并没有真正考虑旅行的负担。你知道，在某种程度上，我想当你年轻的时候，你去新的地方，你很兴奋。我不是说我不兴奋去匹兹堡，但第一次或第二次我去匹兹堡，或者在匹兹堡，这很有趣，因为我喜欢去
into what the city's all about and learn about the city and meet some people there. Well, the 80th time is a little bit different. The 80th time is, you know, make sure that you get night turn down service. That's the important thing on the 80th trip. So yeah, this is part of, you know, if this is the worst part of the business, and I've been doing this for, well, 55 years now, starting in minor league baseball in Hawaii back in 1968. And we're going to get into that. This is the worst thing. This is one of the great jobs of all time and believing. I don't want to come back in the next life because if God wants to get even with me in my next life, I'll be working in a sulfur mine in Mongolia on the night shift. Yeah. Well, well, you know, Al, one of the things that's
了解这个城市的一切，了解这个城市，在那里结识一些人。嗯，第80次就有点不同了。第80次是，你知道，确保你有夜间开夜床服务。这是第80次旅行中重要的事情。所以是的，这是，你知道，如果这是这个行业最糟糕的部分，我已经做了，嗯，现在55年了，1968年在夏威夷的小联盟棒球开始。我们要深入探讨这一点。这是最糟糕的事情。这是有史以来最伟大的工作之一，相信我。我不想在下辈子回来，因为如果上帝想在下辈子报复我，我会在蒙古的硫磺矿里上夜班。是的。好吧，好吧，你知道，阿尔，其中一件事情
so striking about you, and it's so great to see you man. And, you know, obviously you've called so many iconic games over the years, maybe none more than the miracle and ice, do you believe in miracles call, which is so famous. And I don't know if you remember last year when we played together with, I gave you shit about it. And I said, as a Canadian, I feel like, you know, a lot of our pros Gretzky at the time, they weren't playing on that team. And you're like, just let us have this. Why do you have to? And you're just basically in my face. You're like, shut up. But one of the things I love, Al, is that you obviously, and because I want to get into how you started doing this, you obviously have a love of sport. And the way that I confirmed
非常引人注目的是你，见到你真是太好了，伙计。而且，你知道，显然你多年来解说过这么多标志性的比赛，也许没有比“冰上奇迹”更重要的了，你相信奇迹吗，这非常出名。我不知道你是否记得去年我们一起打球时，我拿它开玩笑。我说，作为一个加拿大人，我觉得，你知道，我们的很多职业选手格雷茨基当时，他们没有在那支球队里。你说，就让我们拥有这个吧。你为什么一定要？你基本上就在我面前。你说，闭嘴。但我喜欢的一件事，阿尔，是因为你显然，而且因为我想深入了解你是如何开始做这个的，你显然对体育有热爱。我确认的方式
your real love of it was the first time I went to, I used my buddy Louis K's tickets for a Kings game. And I go and I sit with my buddy and who's sitting behind me, but Al and his son. And I'm like, on his off nights, just taking the game. He's taking it in a game. He's at a Kings game. And he's not calling the game. You're there as a fan. I'm like, this is a sports fan. What if you turned around and he was calling the game from that scene? Just in the sun's ear, just whispering. Will and I both know that hockey is fantastic. And I'm sorry we had to take, you know, the gold medal and even though Canada may have had better players at that time, but will, I mean, sooner or later, your ship's going to come in. The Toronto Maple Leafs will, will in our lifetime
你真正的热爱是第一次我去，我用了我好友路易斯·K的票去看国王队的比赛。我去和我朋友坐在一起，谁坐在我后面，是阿尔和他儿子。我心想，在他休息的晚上，只是看比赛。他在看一场比赛。他在国王队的比赛现场。他没有解说比赛。你作为球迷在那里。我心想，这是一个体育迷。如果你转过身，他正在从那个座位解说比赛呢？就在儿子的耳朵边，只是低声细语。威尔和我都知道冰球太棒了。我很抱歉我们不得不拿走，你知道，金牌，即使加拿大当时可能有更好的球员，但威尔，我的意思是，迟早，你的船会进港的。多伦多枫叶队会，会在我们有生之年
win a Stanley Cup. Yes. That's been a, you're in a desert right now, but I'm feeling the oasis, Will, maybe this year. I mean, Anna hands up, you know, in charge. Our buddy, Shani, who we've had on the program, he's trying as hard as he can. Let's hope. But it is, and thank you, Al. I mean, to Leaf Nation, thanks you. Gosh, maybe we get, maybe we need Al to come up and call some of the games in tandem with our great guys who do it. And that will be the magic touch. You know, like, do you believe in miracles for the Leafs would be incredible. But, but now I do want to get back to you. You're just, your fandom is so deep that there are no offnates because you're always watching sports, right? It's your, it's, is that your true love? I mean, I don't want to put words
赢得斯坦利杯。是的。你现在处于沙漠中，但我感觉到了绿洲，威尔，也许今年。我的意思是，安娜负责。我们的好友沙尼，我们请过他上节目，他正在尽他所能。让我们希望吧。但这确实是，谢谢你，阿尔。我的意思是，枫叶国感谢你。天哪，也许我们得到，也许我们需要阿尔上来和我们伟大的解说员一起解说一些比赛。那将是神奇的触碰。你知道，就像，你相信枫叶队的奇迹吗，那将是不可思议的。但是，但是现在我确实想回到你身上。你的，你的球迷身份太深了，以至于没有休息的晚上，因为你总是看体育比赛，对吧？这是你的，这是，这是你的真爱吗？我的意思是，我不想把话
in. Well, I've always loved sports and my father, look, I grew up in Brooklyn and how many kids can grow up within walking distance of major league baseball. The Brooklyn Dodgers are playing about a 10 minute walk from my apartment. So my father walked me over there when I was a kid. It's the first thing I remember in life. I walked into Evansfield on a Saturday afternoon. The colors just blew me away. I mean, the green grass and, and the Dodger uniforms, which Vince Scully always described as wedding cake white and the signage on the outfield fence and the organist playing and all of this and Jackie Robinson is in the game and Duke Snyder and people like that. So right off the bat, I mean, I could, I can imagine my tongue was out of my
放在你嘴里。嗯，我一直热爱体育，我父亲，看，我在布鲁克林长大，有多少孩子能在步行距离内长大看到职业棒球大联盟。布鲁克林道奇队离我的公寓大约10分钟步行路程。所以我小时候我父亲带我走过去。这是我生命中记得的第一件事。我周六下午走进埃文斯菲尔德。颜色让我惊叹不已。我的意思是，绿色的草地，还有道奇队的制服，文斯·斯库利总是形容为婚礼蛋糕般的白色，外野围栏上的标牌，管风琴手在演奏，所有这些，杰基·罗宾逊在比赛中，还有杜克·斯奈德这样的人。所以一开始，我的意思是，我可以，我可以想象我的舌头都
mouth and I just wanted to be there every night. And that was the Genesis. That's where it started. I knew I wanted to do this forever. And you know, you can dream about something as a kid when you're six or seven. And then, you know, I, I was always confident that I'd be able to do it. And so I set my sights on, on doing this, getting to that point and got there. But I will tell you this, though, it's one thing to look at it from a kid's eyes and say, I can do this. And then when it happens, I look back and I go, holy mackerel, are you kidding me? Do you realize naivete was a great thing because you're so naive, you think you can do it. And then I went, oh boy, and I need about 400 breaks along the way. But why, why, what, why was it about,
嘴里，我只想每天晚上都在那里。这就是起源。这就是它开始的地方。我知道我永远想做这个。而且你知道，当你六七岁的时候，你可以梦想某件事。然后，你知道，我一直很自信我能做到。所以我把目标定在做这个，达到那个点，然后就到了。但我会告诉你这个，虽然，从孩子的眼睛看它说，我能做到，是一回事。然后当它发生时，我回过头去想，天哪，你在开玩笑吗？你意识到天真是一件伟大的事情，因为你太天真了，你认为你能做到。然后我心想，哦，男孩，我沿途需要大约400次机会。但为什么，为什么，为什么是关于，
why wasn't it the dream to play the game? Why was the dream to call the game? Well, it was both actually. So I wound up playing, remember in Brooklyn, there's not a lot of green grass to play. So our games were the street games, punch ball, stick ball, ring, Olivia, stoople, all that stuff. Ring, I didn't have access to real, to real, to real, to real baseball. Ring, Olivia was a game. That's what Will has right now. It's a game where you have to it's a cream for that. I think you put you put people in jail, like in the basement of an apartment building by by bear hunting them, holding them for three seconds, count out cork cork ring, Olivia, one, two, three, they go into jail. And then everybody else has to extricate you from
为什么梦想不是去打比赛？为什么梦想是去解说比赛？嗯，其实两者都是。所以我最终去打球，记得在布鲁克林，没有多少绿草可以打球。所以我们的比赛是街头游戏，拳击球，棍球，Ring-a-levio，跳房子，所有这些东西。Ring-a-levio，我没有接触过真正的，真正的，真正的棒球。Ring-a-levio是一个游戏。这就是威尔现在有的。这是一个游戏，你必须，它有一种奶油。我想你把人关进监狱，就像在公寓楼的地下室里，通过抓捕他们，抓住他们三秒钟，数数，软木塞，软木塞，Ring-a-levio，一，二，三，他们就进监狱了。然后其他人必须把你从
jail. So one day I extricated like all four guys on my team. I was the big hero. But I turned out to be the bomb. He said, cost us the game in the end. But you should have joined the Navy Seals or the Green Berets, it sounds like. Oh, but of course. So that was my second dream, trust me. So then is it safe to say that Vince Scully was the first voice that really kind of sparked your passion for it? Without a doubt. Yeah. So I listened. Vinny was 21 or 22 when he took over. Yeah, that was right when Vince Scully started. He did. How long did he, what was he doing the Dodger stuff? 67 years. 67 years. And one of the great thrills and honors for me in my career was when they asked me, Vinny was going to do his last season in 2016. And they called me to emcee
监狱里救出来。所以有一天我救出了我队里的所有四个人。我是大英雄。但我最终成了炸弹。他说，最后让我们输掉了比赛。但你本应该加入海豹突击队或绿色贝雷帽，听起来像。哦，当然。所以那是我的第二个梦想，相信我。那么可以肯定地说，文斯·斯库利是真正激发你热情的第一个声音吗？毫无疑问。是的。所以我听了。文尼接手时才21或22岁。是的，那正是文斯·斯库利开始的时候。他确实。他做了多久，他在做道奇队的东西？67年。67年。对我职业生涯来说，最伟大的刺激和荣誉之一是当他们问我时，文尼要在2016年做他的最后一个赛季。他们打电话给我，让我在开幕日道奇体育场座无虚席的情况下主持，向文尼致敬。所有老道奇队员，我从小看着长大的那些人都在那里。当然，文尼出来时人群疯狂了。对我来说，一个巨大的刺激，显然不仅是早年听到文尼，小时候听他，当我第一次开始做，有机会做职业棒球大联盟时一直听到他。而且认识他，认识他这么多年，他，他是特别的。他是独一无二的。他是史上最伟大的。没有人能超过那个。当你想到它时，有多少人在任何事情上有67年的职业生涯？关于文尼的一点也是，直到他生命的尽头，我的意思是，我过去常常开车到处转，
at Dodger Stadium before a packed house on opening day, the tribute to Vinny. And all of the old Dodgers, the guys that I've grown up watching play were there. And of course, Vinny came out of the crowd went crazy. And a great thrill, obviously for me was not only to hear Vinny early on, to listen to him as a kid, to hear him all the way through when I first got into do, got to do Major League Baseball. But knowing him, knowing him for so many years, and he was, he was special. He was one of a kind. He was the greatest that ever lived. And nobody will ever exceed that. And when you think about it, how many guys have 67 year careers in anything? And the thing about Vinny too, to the very end of his life, I mean, I used to drive around in
2014、15、16年，当他职业生涯进入最后阶段时。我会听比赛，比赛其实并没有那么有趣。但文尼会让它有趣10倍。如果他在讲故事，我开进车道，在打开车库门之前，我不得不坐在车里，让它空转。让我听文尼讲完那个故事。他是现象级的。没人像他。我突然想到，你一定和他打过很多高尔夫球，对吧？因为你们都在同一个，同一个高尔夫球场。他是个高尔夫球手吗？我刚加入俱乐部时，在93年和文尼一起打过球，那时文尼还在打很多球。有一次在第10洞，你们知道，你必须把它打过
2014, 15, 16, when he's coming down the stretch of his career. And I'd be listening to the game and the game really wouldn't be that interesting. But Vinny would make it 10 times more interesting. And if he was telling a story, and I pulled into the driveway, before I opened up the garage door, I had to sit in the car, letting it idle. And let me hear Vin finish that story. He was phenomenal. Nobody liked him. And it occurs to me, you must have played a ton of golf with him, right? Because you're all up at the same, the same golf course. Was he much of a golf player? I play, I hacked it around with Vinny. When I first joined the club in 93, Vinny was still playing a lot at that time. And one time on number 10, and you guys know, you have to hit it across the
峡谷大约120码。很多球最终没能打过去。而且，你知道，我打了一个糟糕的球，大约40码，直接掉进沟里，结束了。他们为那个挥杆写歌。它们通常是悲伤的乡村歌曲。对。对。他是一个打高尔夫球的好人，认识的好人，一起吃饭的好人。我非常激动和荣幸能成为，你知道，他真正处于顶峰的行业的一部分。是的，他永远是我最喜欢的道奇队员。我们马上回来。SmartLess由FanDuel赞助。嘿，伙计们，NBA赛季的中点到了，现在是下载美国第一体育博彩公司FanDuel的最佳时机，
ravine about 120 yards. And so many balls wind up not going over. And, you know, I had a terrible shot went about 40 yards and right down into the gully and finish it. They write songs about that swing. They're usually sad country songs. Right. Right. He was a wonderful man to play golf with, wonderful man to know, wonderful man to have a meal with. And I'm so thrilled and honored to have been a part of, you know, a part of an industry that he really sits at the top of. Yeah, he'll always be my favorite dodger. We'll be right back. SmartLess is brought to you by FanDuel. Hey guys, the midway point of the NBA season is here, and now is the perfect time to download FanDuel America's number one sportsbook,
因为新客户可以获得高达1000美元的无压力首注。如果你的第一笔投注没赢，会有奖金投注返还。只需下载FanDuel体育博彩应用程序。它安全、可靠，而且超级容易使用。然后你可以投注从胜负盘到得分点和三分球的一切。你知道，我喜欢投注。我喜欢赌博。我喜欢拉斯维加斯。我喜欢这一切。就像，可能有点太过了，但那是另一个播客，甚至可能是治疗师的事。但听着，看，如果他们有像音乐剧那样的东西，我们可以投注音乐剧，比如，嘿，谁会赢得布景设计和服装？你知道，最佳歌曲。我不知道。我可以那样做，而且我会赢。就像，我可以赢。就像，我可能会在FanDuel上赢。
because new customers get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. That's bonus bets back if your first bet doesn't win. Just download the FanDuel sportsbook app. It's safe, secure, and super easy to use. Then you can bet on everything from the money line to point scores and threes drained. You know, I love betting. I love gambling. I love Vegas. I love all of it. Like, probably a little too much, but that's for another podcast and maybe even a therapist. But listen, look, if they had like a musical thing, we could bet on musicals like, hey, who's going to win set design and costumes? You know, best song. I don't know. I could do that, and I'd win. And just like, I could win at it. Like, I'd probably win at FanDuel.
所以顺便说一句，FanDuel甚至让你组合你的投注，以获得更大赔率的机会，这叫做同场连赢。所以不要错过机会，当你去FanDuel.com/SmartLess时，获得高达1000美元的无压力首注奖金。那是FanDuel.com/SmartLess以了解更多。让每一刻都与FanDuel更精彩，NBA的官方体育博彩合作伙伴。21岁以上，适用排除条款。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。嘿，SmartLess听众，我们确实得到了Helix的支持。所以我不知道你知不知道，我想我之前在节目中提到过，斯科蒂和我因为打呼噜的问题分房睡。但关于我的Helix Dusk Lux床垫，最棒的是什么？我可以像海星一样躺着。
So by the way, FanDuel even lets you combine your bets for a chance at a bigger payout with something called a same game parlay. So don't miss the chance to get your no sweat first bet up to $1,000 in bonus bets when you go to FanDuel.com slash SmartLess. That's FanDuel.com slash SmartLess to learn more. Make every moment more with FanDuel, an official sports betting partner of the NBA. 21 plus exclusions. Apply C-show notes for full disclaimer. Hey, SmartLess listener, we get support literally from Helix. So I don't know if you know, I think I mentioned it before on the show that Scotty and I sleep in separate rooms because of a snoring issue. But here's what's great about my Helix Dusk Lux mattress. I can starfish it.
我像海星一样向四面八方伸展开来，我在我的Helix Dusk Lux上睡得不可思议。我不会起床。如果我起床去小便，我马上又睡着了。它就像，包裹着我。它是最温暖、最伟大的床垫。Helix系列包括14种独特的床垫，包括一系列豪华型号，适合高大睡眠者的床垫，甚至还有专门为儿童制作的床垫。有些型号有记忆泡沫层，如果你侧睡，可以提供最佳的压力缓解，或者有些型号有反应更灵敏的泡沫，可以包裹你的身体，为胃部和背部睡眠姿势提供必要的支撑。Helix被GQ和Wired杂志评为第一床垫选择。
I'm spread out in all directions like a starfish, and I sleep incredibly on my Helix Dusk Lux. I don't get up. If I get up to pee, I go right back to sleep. And it's like, it envelopes me. It's the warmest, greatest mattress. The Helix lineup includes 14 unique mattresses, including a collection of luxury models, a mattress for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. There are models with memory foam layers to provide optimal pressure relief if you sleep on your side, or models with a more responsive foam to cradle your body for essential support in stomach and back sleeping positions. Helix has been awarded the number one mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine.
它甚至被多位领先的脊椎按摩师和睡眠医学医生推荐为改善睡眠的首选解决方案。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单最高20%的折扣和两个免费枕头。去helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更好的睡眠现在就开始。我们得到了State Farm的支持。当你能个性化你的体验时，生活会更好，比如在你的播客订阅源中选择那恰到好处的节目组合，或者为你的当前氛围选择最好的锻炼播放列表。你知道我的意思吗？个性化意味着你有权选择你想要包含的内容，并排除你不想要的内容。那样感觉更好。
It's even recommended by multiple leading chiropractors and doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to solution for improving your sleep. Helix is offering up to 20% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet, and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. We get support from State Farm. Life is just better when you can personalize your experiences, like choosing that just right mix of shows in your podcast feed or picking the best workout playlist for your current vibes. You know what I mean? Personalization means you have the power to choose what you want to include and leave out what you don't. It just feels better that way.
为什么保险不应该那样工作呢？这就是State Farm个人价格计划的全部内容。你可以选择包含诸如捆绑你的家庭和汽车保单之类的选项，这意味着你将以适合你的实惠价格获得你想要的保险。最终，你将拥有一份给你想要的保单。这感觉不是已经更好吗？就像一个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。今天就致电或访问statefarm.com来创建你的State Farm个人价格计划。价格因州而异，客户选择的选项可用性，以及生活几率可能会有所不同。好了，回到节目。所以你是一个来自布鲁克林的玩所有这些游戏的孩子，玩提取器，无论什么Ring-a-levio
And why shouldn't insurance work like that too? That's what the State Farm personal price plan is all about. You can choose to include options like bundling your home and auto policies, which means you'll get the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you. In the end, you'll have a policy that gives you what you want. Doesn't that feel better already? Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Call or go to statefarm.com today to create your State Farm personal price plan. Prices vary by state, options selected by customer availability, and odds of living may vary. All right, back to the show. So you're a kid from Brooklyn playing all these games, playing extractor, whatever the ringleader
你在提取。但后来你就在那里，你做所有这些事情，你对体育有热爱，对解说体育有热爱，你知道你是怎么实现那个飞跃的？一个来自布鲁克林的孩子是怎么成为阿尔·迈克尔斯的？你做的第一件事是什么，你心想，我必须迈出这一步？是的，是什么让你去了夏威夷？你在夏威夷起步，对吧？在那里解说小联盟棒球？在那之前，我去了这里洛杉矶的汉密尔顿高中，在10年级遇到了一个叫琳达·乔治的女孩。爱琳达。好的，那是，是的，你爱琳达，你知道琳达。不，我们都知道琳达。她是我生命中的爱。对。我们，哦，来自汉密尔顿的琳达。琳达·汉密尔顿。好的，记得什么？对，我们在10年级时是领带。然后我，
you're extracting. But then so you're there and you're doing all this stuff and you have a love for sports and a love for calling sports and you know how do you make that leap? How does a kid from Brooklyn become Al Michaels? What's the first thing that you go, I got to take this step? Yeah, what got you out to Hawaii? You started in Hawaii, right? Calling minor league baseball out there? Before that, I went to Hamilton High School here in Los Angeles, met a girl named Linda George in the 10th grade. Love Linda. Okay, that's, yep, you love Linda, you know Linda. No, we all knew Linda. She's in love with my life. Right. And we, oh, Linda from Hamilton. Linda Hamilton. All right, remember something? Right, we were ties on 10th grade. And then I,
我父亲也热爱体育。所以当我准备上大学时，我们查了一些学校，记得，这是在60年代。现在每所学校都有广播和电视节目，对吧，你可以主修它。那些年没有。不，有，只有几所学校有那种类型的项目。我们在1958年从纽约搬到了洛杉矶，当时我在10年级。所以这就是我来到这里的原因。所以我们看了所有的学校，我喜欢西部的。我不想回东部，喜欢那里的天气。所以有，当时只有两所学校有那种项目。一个是南加州大学，一个是亚利桑那州立大学。南加州大学对我来说是通勤，住家里，去学校，
my father loves sports as well. And so when I was ready to go to college, we looked up some schools that, remember, this is in the 60s. Every school right now has a radio and TV program and right, you can major in it. Not in those years. No, there were, there were only a couple of schools that had had that type of program. And we had moved from New York to Los Angeles in 1958, when I was in the 10th grade. So that's what got me here. And so we looked at all of the schools and I liked it out of West. I didn't want to go back East, love the weather. So there were, there were only two schools that had that sort of a program at that time. One was USC, and one was Arizona State. And USC was going to be a commute for me, live at home, go to school,
你知道，10英里远。不，我想有，完整的体验。所以我们去了坦佩的亚利桑那州立大学，见了一些人。我说，我想广播体育。他们说，好吧，你来这里，我们有一个校园广播电台，我们用学生广播比赛。所以如果你来，如果你来，也许，你知道，到你第三年，我们可以让你进入那个行列。我去了那里，六天之内，六天之内，伙计们，我就在广播了，我在做亚利桑那州立大学对科罗拉多州立大学的比赛，因为有人退出了校园广播电台。在那些日子里，它被称为载波电流，这意味着你可以在女性锅炉房里接收到信号，也许，离那里一个半街区远。这就是它能达到的最远距离。但我最终做了比赛。而且最
you know, 10 miles away. No, I wanted to have the, the full experience. So we went down to ASU in Tempe, met with some people. I said, I want to broadcast sports. They say, well, you come down here, we have a campus radio station and we broadcast the games with students. So if you come down, if you come down, maybe, you know, by your third year, we can get you into, into that mix. I go down there and within six days, within six days, guys, I'm on the air, I'm doing Arizona State, Colorado State, because somebody dropped out on a campus radio station. It was known as a carrier current in those days, which meant you could pick up the signal in the women's boiler rooms, perhaps, and maybe a block and a half away. That's as far as it went. But I wound up doing games. And of all
奇怪的是，我最终和一支全国冠军棒球队一起上学，一个叫萨尔·班多的家伙，10年后我在世界大赛中宣布他，当时我在红人队，他在奥克兰。里克·蒙迪进来了，里克还在道奇队的广播里。当我，当我大三时，我们有一个叫雷吉·杰克逊的大一新生。所以雷吉进来了。这太疯狂了。我们有伟大的橄榄球队，查理·泰勒，库利·库尔珀在名人堂，我最终做了橄榄球、篮球、棒球。我可能在亚利桑那州立大学的校园电台上宣布了200场棒球比赛，什么也没得到。这帮助我得到了我的第一份专业工作，那是在夏威夷，因为我至少有一个磁带可以给总经理，一个叫
things, I wound up going to school with a national championship baseball team, a guy named Sal Bando, who 10 years later I announced in a, in a World Series when I'm with the Reds and he's with Oakland. Rick Monday comes in, Rick is still on the Dodger broadcast. And when I'm a, when I'm a junior, we have a freshman by the name of Reggie Jackson. So Reggie comes in. That's crazy. We had great football teams, Charlie Taylor, Curly Culper in the Hall of Fame, and I wound up doing football, basketball, baseball. I probably announced 200 baseball games going nowhere on the campus station at Arizona State. And that helped me get my first professional job, which was in Hawaii, because I at least had a tape to give to the general manager, a man named
杰克·昆特的人，我欠他一切，因为他给了我机会在1968年去夏威夷，做小联盟棒球。到这一切结束时，我在那里做所有事情，篮球、棒球、排球，你说得出名字的，我一天上两次电视。夏威夷小联盟棒球的观众规模是多少？我的意思是，那超过100人吗？不，不，他们在太平洋海岸联盟。所以我们和像凤凰城和图森这样的球队比赛，并且旅行。西雅图当时没有职业大联盟球队。圣地亚哥也没有，丹佛在这个联盟里。所以太平洋海岸联盟的球队会过来和夏威夷比赛。所以我们的大对手是斯波坎印第安人队。斯波坎在那些年是道奇队的农场俱乐部。
Jack Quint, to whom I own everything, for giving me the opportunity to come over to Hawaii in 1968, do minor league baseball. And by the time that was all said and done, I was doing everything over there, basketball, baseball, volleyball, you name it, I'm on television twice a day. What is the audience size of minor league Hawaii baseball? I mean, is that more than 100 people? No, no, they were in the Pacific Coast League. So we were playing at teams like Phoenix and Tucson and traveling. And Seattle did not have a major league team at that time. Neither did San Diego, Denver's in that league. So the Pacific Coast League teams would come over and play Hawaii. So our big rival was the Spokane Indians. And Spokane in those years was the Dodger farm club.
他们是总裁是彼得·奥马利。他们由汤米·拉索塔管理。不，球员包括史蒂夫·加维、戴维·洛佩斯、比尔·拉塞尔、鲍比·瓦伦丁、比尔·巴克纳。我只讲一个来自拉索塔的简短故事。因为拉索塔总是把我的职业生涯归功于他。所以我们的大对手是斯波坎。所以1970年，我们在那里。由于旅行费用和限制，球队过来不是三天或四天，而是七天，他们在那儿待一整周。所以我非常了解这些球队。所以在夏威夷和斯波坎之间七场系列赛的第三场比赛中，拉索塔在第三局被罚出场。你知道，汤米，汤米到处都是。现在在夏威夷，没有通往会所的休息区通道。你走
They were the president was Peter O'Malley. They were managed by Tommy LaSorta. No, the players included Steve Garvey, Davey Lopes, Bill Russell, Bobby Valentine, Bill Buckner. And I'll just give you one quick story from LaSorta. Because LaSorta always took credit for my career. So our big rival is Spokane. So in 1970, we're over there. And because of travel expenses and restrictions, teams would come over not for three days or four days, but for seven days, they spend the whole week there. So I got to know these teams very well. So in the third game of a seven game series between Hawaii and Spokane, LaSorta gets thrown out of the game in the third inning. You know, Tommy, Tommy's all over the place. Now in Hawaii, there's no dugout access to a clubhouse. You walk
480英尺穿过这个中外野围栏。会所就在那之外100英尺。所以你不能像很多经理过去常做的那样溜回比赛。所以拉索塔走了。他在会所里。你第二天晚上不能被看到。他非常生气，以至于他出来，当他与所有人交换阵容卡时，布鲁斯·弗里明，他后来成为了一名职业大联盟裁判，拥有37年的职业生涯，他在交换阵容卡时被罚出场，在比赛开始前。所以他在那里。他再次走了那条路。人群在为他唱歌。他多坚持了一场比赛。现在第六场比赛，他在大约第六局又被罚出场。好的。所以他在六个晚上被罚出了三场比赛。他总是讲这个故事
480 feet throughout through this out the center field fence. And the clubhouse is 100 feet beyond that. So you can't sneak back into the game like a lot of managers used to do. So LaSorta is gone. He's out in the clubhouse. You can't be seen the next night. He's so angry that he comes out and as he exchanges lineup cards with all people, Bruce Frimming, who would go on to like a 37 year career as a major league umpire, he gets thrown out of the game with the exchange of lineup cards before the game before the game starts. So there he is. He makes that walk again. The crowd is singing to him. He'd last one more game. Now the sixth game, he gets thrown out again at about the sixth. Okay. So he's been thrown out of three games in six nights. He always tells the story
关于他如何在每场比赛后打电话给阿尔·坎帕尼斯，他是总经理，向坎帕尼斯报告，当时洛杉矶道奇队的总经理，告诉他伙计们表现如何。瓦伦丁四打二，巴克纳做了这个，某某投了六局，等等，等等。所以拉索塔告诉，根据拉索塔的说法，在其中一个电话中告诉坎帕尼斯，嘿，你知道，嘿，阿尔，我知道你有文斯·斯库利，文尼很棒。他会待很长时间。但这里有个孩子。有个孩子。他在宣布棒球。这个孩子，这个孩子，这个孩子真的很好。他的名字是迈克尔斯。是阿尔·迈克尔斯。你应该关注这个孩子。谈话继续进行。他们准备结束谈话。坎帕尼斯对拉索塔说，嘿，汤米，这个家伙，
about how he calls Al Campanus, who's the general manager after every game to report Campanus, the GM of the LA Dodgers at that point to tell him how the guys did. Valentine went two for four, Buckner did this, so-and-so pitched six innings, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So LaSorta tells, according to LaSorta tells Campanus in one of those calls, hey, you know, hey, Al, I know you got Vince Gully, Vinny's great. He's going to be there a long time. But there's this kid over here. There's this kid. He's announcing baseball. And this kid is, this kid's, this kid's really good. His name is Michael's. It's Al Michael's. You should keep an eye on this kid. The conversation goes on. They're ready to end the conversation. Campanus says to LaSorta, hey, Tommy, this guy,
关于他如何在每场比赛后给总经理阿尔·坎帕尼斯打电话汇报情况，坎帕尼斯当时是洛杉矶道奇队的总经理，他会告诉他球员们的表现。瓦伦丁四打数两安打，巴克纳做了这个，某某投了六局，等等等等。据拉索达所说，他在其中一次通话中告诉坎帕尼斯，嘿，你知道，阿尔，我知道你有文斯·斯库利，文尼很棒。他会待很长时间。但这里有个孩子。有个孩子。他在播报棒球比赛。这个孩子，这个孩子，这个孩子真的很棒。他叫迈克尔斯。是阿尔·迈克尔斯。你应该留意一下这个孩子。谈话继续进行。他们准备结束谈话。坎帕尼斯对拉索达说，嘿，汤米，这家伙，
Michael, is this kid you're talking about? How do you know he's any good? Tommy said, I've been thrown out of the last four games of sitting down in the clubhouse listening to him. So LaSorta died that on that story. It's a little bit of an embellishment, but a lot of truth to it. I love that he got thrown out with the lineup cards. I don't wonder if that's ever happened again. Unbelievable. Speaking of being thrown out, and you just mentioned Bobby Valentine, one of the all-time great throwouts. Bobby Valentine, Sean, I don't know if you know this. When he was the manager of the Mets, he got thrown out of the game and he came back in in disguise. He wore a fake mustache and glasses. True story. In Major League Baseball, like in the 90s, right out.
迈克尔，你说的就是这孩子吗？你怎么知道他有两把刷子？汤米说，我被罚出场外，坐在更衣室里听他解说，这已经是最近四场比赛里的事了。所以拉索塔（LaSorta）对这个故事深信不疑。虽然有点夸张，但大部分是事实。我喜欢他拿着排阵卡被罚出场的那段，不知道后来还有没有发生过这种事。简直不可思议。说到被罚出场，你刚才提到了鲍比·瓦伦丁（Bobby Valentine），他是史上最著名的被罚出场者之一。肖恩，不知道你知不知道，当他在大都会队当教练时，他被罚出场后竟然乔装打扮又溜了回来。他戴着假胡子和眼镜。这是真事。在90年代的美国职业棒球大联盟里，直接被罚出去了。
For sure. I remember that very well. You know, it's so funny because on that Dodger team, which was so good, this is the team of Garvey and Russell and Buckner and Lopes. And they'd go on to, you know, in championships when they all got called up. I thought, and I think Tommy did, and I think a lot of the Dodger organization people felt, Valentine was the best of the players. But Bobby kept getting hurt. Bobby's whole career was injury prone. So Bobby had, you know, five or six very significant injuries. And so he never quite lived up to what was expected of him as a player. He's a great athlete, though. And then he becomes a great manager. So, Al, so you're there and you're in Hawaii. You're calling all these games. You've had all this experience kind of goes to that idea of
确实。我记得很清楚。你知道，这太搞笑了，因为在那支道奇队里，那支球队非常出色，那是加维（Garvey）、拉塞尔（Russell）、巴克纳（Buckner）和洛佩斯（Lopes）的时代。他们后来在被征召后都赢得了冠军。我当时想，汤米也这么想，而且我觉得很多道奇队的人都觉得，瓦伦丁是球员里最出色的。但鲍比总是受伤。鲍比整个职业生涯都容易受伤。所以鲍比有过五六次非常严重的伤病。因此，他作为球员的表现从未完全达到人们的预期。不过他是个伟大的运动员。后来他成了一名伟大的教练。那么，阿尔，你当时在夏威夷，解说了所有这些比赛。你拥有这么多经验，这有点符合那个观点……
like the 10,000 hours. You're calling, you're talking into a vacuum in Arizona State. There's nobody listening. But you're getting those hours under you. And then you go and you're calling minor league games and you're getting more experience. So then what is the big break moment where you start going on a national stage? What's that first gig? Three years in Hawaii. So it's the end of the 1970s season. We had had a very successful year. We launched the Spokane and the championship series, but we drew over 400,000 people in Hawaii. So we were at, you know, we were putting a lot of people in that stadium every night. And it was a big, big deal in the sporting news that a big story on Hawaii baseball. And the Cincinnati Reds were looking for a new
就像“一万小时定律”。你在亚利桑那州立大学对着真空解说，没人听。但你积累了那些时间。然后你去解说小联盟比赛，获得了更多经验。那么，你开始登上全国舞台的那个重大转折点是什么？第一份工作是什么？在夏威夷待了三年。那是1970年赛季结束时。我们度过了非常成功的一年。我们发起了斯波坎（Spokane）和冠军系列赛，但在夏威夷吸引了超过40万人。所以我们当时每晚都在那个体育场里容纳了很多人。这在《体育新闻》上是一件大事，关于夏威夷棒球的大新闻。辛辛那提红人队正在寻找一位新的……
announcer. I don't know what happened to the guy who was there before, but somebody in Cincinnati, somebody, a man's name was Dick Wagner, who was in charge of trying to find somebody to come in and be the broadcaster. And he had called somebody at NBC who knew about me and said, you should look at this kid. So I get a call from the Reds in November of 70. I mean, it's a weekend when I'm doing five football games. I'm doing four high school games in the University of Hawaii. I'm doing five games in a weekend. But now they put me on a red eye after the fifth game on that Saturday night. They fly me to Cincinnati to be interviewed for the Reds job. Now this is the Reds coming into the 1971 season. They had just been in the World Series. They lost to Baltimore. That's the Brooks
播音员。我不知道之前在那儿的那个人怎么了，但辛辛那提有人，那个人的名字叫迪克·瓦格纳（Dick Wagner），他负责寻找接替的广播员。他给NBC的一个认识我的人打了电话，说你应该看看这个孩子。于是我在70年11月接到了红人队的电话。那是一个周末，我正在解说五场橄榄球比赛。我解说了四场高中比赛和夏威夷大学的比赛。我一个周末解说了五场比赛。但现在，他们在周六晚上的第五场比赛后让我坐红眼航班。他们飞我到辛辛那提去面试红人队的工作。这是红人队进入1971年赛季的时候。他们刚打进世界大赛。他们输给了巴尔的摩。那是布鲁克斯……
Robinson series where Robinson is fantastic. So all of a sudden I'm in Cincinnati. I'm 26 years old, and I'm going to get the Cincinnati Reds number one job. I'm going to a team with Pete Rose in his prime, Johnny Bench coming into his prime, Tony Perez in his prime, Davey Concepcion, Joe Morgan getting traded over the next year, and Sparky Anderson, Hall of Fame manager. I'm coming to that team. Wow. So it was kind of crazy because you know, it was really weird though. In Cincinnati, it's like November the 16th, and I meet the team or I meet the brass in an office downtown of the Central Trust Tower, and I walk outside and it's like 38 degrees and it's sleeting, and I'm walking back to Stoffers Hotel, which is about three blocks, and Linda's in Hawaii,
罗宾逊（Robinson）系列赛，罗宾逊表现得太棒了。所以突然之间我就在辛辛那提了。我26岁，我要得到辛辛那提红人队的一号职位。我要去一支拥有巅峰期皮特·罗斯（Pete Rose）、正值巅峰的约翰尼·本奇（Johnny Bench）、巅峰期的托尼·佩雷斯（Tony Perez）、戴维·康塞普西翁（Davey Concepcion）、下一年被交易过来的乔·摩根（Joe Morgan），以及名人堂教练斯帕基·安德森（Sparky Anderson）的球队。我要加入那支球队。哇。这太疯狂了，因为你知道，这真的很奇怪。在辛辛那提，那是11月16日，我在市中心的中央信托大厦办公室见到了球队或管理层，我走出来，外面大概38华氏度（约3摄氏度），还下着雨夹雪，我走回斯托弗酒店（Stoffers Hotel），大概三个街区，而琳达还在夏威夷，
and we have our son, our baby, as a year or two old at that time, and I walk by standing on the corner waiting for the light to change. I'm freezing to death, and you know, the colors in Cincinnati at that time of year are two colors. They're brown and gray. That's it. And I'm thinking of Hawaii where it's all, you know, blue and green and beautiful and flowery. And I look into the window of a travel agency, and I can see my apartment at Diamond Head in the poster, and I'm looking now, I look across the street, I look back at this, I'm going, huh, I'm making a leap. Of course, I had, you know, I'm lying in bed that night, they're going to announce the thing the next day. Joe Nuxol is going to be my partner. I can't sleep at all, at all, but I'm thinking to myself
那时我们有个一两岁的儿子，我走过街角，等着红绿灯变色。我冷得要死，你知道，辛辛那提那个季节的颜色只有两种。棕色和灰色。就是这样。我想到夏威夷，那里到处都是蓝色、绿色，美丽且鲜花盛开。我看向一家旅行社的窗户，我能在海报上看到我在钻石山的公寓，我看着现在，我看向街对面，我回头看这一切，我想，哈，我正在迈出一大步。当然，那天晚上我躺在床上，他们第二天就要宣布这件事了。乔·纳克索尔（Joe Nuxhall）将成为我的搭档。我根本睡不着，一点也睡不着，但我心里在想……
at about five in the morning, you know what, I'll go, I'll get up, I'll do this press conference, I'll get on the plane, they'll never see me again, I'm going back to Hawaii, and I'm not coming back. But of course, you know, it all worked out well, I got on the plane, and then they get off in Hawaii, and I go by one of those racks, you know, seven or eight hours later, I land in Honolulu, and one of the newspaper racks is there, and there's the Honolulu store at Bolton, and there I am on the front page, Islanders losing their voice to Reds, and I'm going, I've got, I gotta go, I can't stop now. Anyway, you can't go now, you can't, no, I could not, that would have been the end of my career. But talk about two opposites, yeah, from Hawaii to
大约凌晨五点的时候，你知道吗，我会起床，参加这个新闻发布会，坐上飞机，他们就再也见不到我了，我要回夏威夷，我再也不回来了。但当然，你知道，一切都很顺利，我上了飞机，然后在夏威夷下机，七八个小时后，我经过那些报刊架，你知道，我降落在檀香山，其中一个报刊架就在那儿，上面有檀香山星报，我就在头版上，岛民队失去了他们的声音，转投红人队，我想，我得走了，我现在不能停下来。不管怎样，你现在不能走，你不能，不，我不能，那将是我职业生涯的终点。但说到两个极端，是的，从夏威夷到……
Cincinnati, that was, now speak to Cincinnati. Jason, did you notice something though before you said, did you notice something great that Al just did in that story? He remembered the month, you remembered the day, who does that sound like? That sounds like Mary Lou Henner. Al, I do the same thing, I can remember dates, I can remember the actual day of the month, I do the same thing. He's a one-trick pony, guys, so Al, my next question. Hey, wait a minute, wait, before we get off Mary Lou Henner, because this reminds me, I've never met her, Jimmy Burroughs is a great friend of all of ours, another guy you've had on the podcast. The great, the good, the great, the fantastic, the over-the-moon Jimmy Burroughs,
辛辛那提，那是，现在说说辛辛那提。杰森，你在他说之前注意到什么了吗？你注意到阿尔刚才讲的那个故事里有什么了不起的地方吗？他记得月份，你记得日期，这听起来像谁？这听起来像玛丽·卢·亨纳（Mary Lou Henner）。阿尔，我也做同样的事，我能记住日期，我能记住具体的几号，我也做同样的事。伙计们，他只会这一招，所以阿尔，我的下一个问题。嘿，等一下，等等，在我们离开玛丽·卢·亨纳的话题之前，因为这让我想起，我从没见过她，吉米·伯罗斯（Jimmy Burroughs）是我们所有人的好朋友，也是你请上过播客的另一个人。那位伟大的、优秀的、了不起的、棒极了的、令人赞叹的吉米·伯罗斯，
we all love Jimmy. Been a long time friend of mine, you guys know him well. So his book party, and you guys sent him on to promote his book, fantastic book. And he wanted me, he always wanted me to meet Mary Lou Henner, who was there, but I had to be back in New York for a wedding that weekend, so I couldn't do that. But it reminded me of, you know, Mary, one day I've got to meet Mary Lou, I think she, she's deeper into this thing than me, because she seems to remember like everything she was doing every minute of the day. I'm only good for about three hours each day. Just tell my sister Tracy, Mary Lou Henner, and now Will Arnett, are famous for this kind of recall, recalling days and dates and all that. I can't do it on the same level, obviously,
我们都爱吉米。他是我多年的朋友，你们都很了解他。所以他的新书发布会，你们派他去宣传他的书，那是一本很棒的书。他想让我去，他一直想让我见见也在那儿的玛丽·卢·亨纳，但我那个周末必须回纽约参加婚礼，所以我没能去。但这让我想起，你知道，玛丽，有一天我一定要见见玛丽·卢，我觉得她在这方面比我更深，因为她似乎能记住她每天每分钟在做的一切。我每天只能记住大约三个小时。就告诉我的妹妹特雷西，玛丽·卢·亨纳，还有现在的威尔·阿内特（Will Arnett），都以这种记忆力闻名，能回忆起日子、日期等等。我显然做不到同样的水平，
that Mary Lou can, and I don't even know if I can do it the way Al did. Like Al, Al just said, the date, November 16th, Stofer Hotel, 38 degrees, walking three blocks to the thing. And I know that detail is important. I love the way Al paints the picture, and when he puts those details in, they make it more complete, rather than you two schmoes who go like, yeah, I was there the other day, whatever, and that's why nobody's interested when you talk, because you guys are just these boring and you're so self-involved that you don't paint a picture. If you're a real schmoe, though, you've got an incredible talent, and you haven't figured out how to monetize it, you know? I mean, Al's making money with it, you're just wasting it, you know? That's true,
玛丽·卢能做到的，我甚至不知道我能不能像阿尔那样做。就像阿尔，阿尔刚才说了，日期，11月16日，斯托弗酒店，38度，走三个街区到那儿。我知道那个细节很重要。我喜欢阿尔描绘画面方式，当他加入那些细节时，它们让画面更完整，而不是像你们两个笨蛋那样说，是的，我前几天在那儿，随便吧，这就是为什么你们说话时没人感兴趣，因为你们只是这些无聊的人，而且你们太自我中心了，以至于你们没能描绘出画面。不过，如果你是个真正的笨蛋，你却有惊人的天赋，而且你还没弄清楚怎么把它变现，你知道吗？我是说，阿尔靠这个赚钱，你们只是在浪费它，你知道吗？那是真的，
that's fair, that's fair. Hey, well, I messed up. I looked it up. It was 37 degrees that day. Oh, wow, that's all out the window. The whole thing falls apart. Anyway, so Mary Lou reminded me of Jimmy Burroughs, and I wanted to talk about Jimmy, because I talked to Jimmy yesterday, and I told him I'm coming on the show, and he described you guys as my three sons is what he said. He said, those guys, yeah, meanwhile, you know, Sean, he really is like a, he's like a father to me. Well, I said to him, and Sean was excited about this, but I said, you know, I said, are they in your will? And the phone line went dead. Yeah. There's enough room for us in that will. I always tease them.
那很公平，那很公平。嘿，好吧，我搞砸了。我查了一下。那天是37度。哦，哇，那一切都泡汤了。整件事都崩溃了。不管怎样，所以玛丽·卢让我想起了吉米·伯罗斯，我想谈谈吉米，因为我昨天和吉米谈过，我告诉他我要上这个节目，他形容你们是“我的三个儿子”，他是这么说的。他说，那些家伙，是的，与此同时，你知道，肖恩，他真的就像一个，他就像我的父亲。好吧，我对他说，肖恩对此很兴奋，但我对他说，你知道，我说，他们在你的遗嘱里吗？电话线那头沉默了。是的。遗嘱里有我们的位置。我总是逗他们。
By the way, you know what Jimmy was doing yesterday? He was out, he was putting in a new mailbox piece, the old one, there was some such spillover from the residuals and the royalties that they were dropping into the street. All right, now, this is going to be one in a series of questions that you're so tired of answering. I apologize, but I have probably questions I have too. Yeah, but what do you want for dinner? Right? Well, so, you know, how about your favorite sport to call or the hardest sport to call your choice there? I'll bet the hardest is hockey, just because of all the shift changes. Absolutely. See, because in every other sport, somebody has the ball and the other teams on defense. Yeah. And that is the case, obviously,
顺便问一下，你知道吉米昨天在做什么吗？他在外面，他在装一个新的邮箱，旧的那个，因为剩余收益和版税溢出太多，它们都掉到街上了。好了，现在，这将是你厌倦回答的一系列问题中的一个。我道歉，但我可能也有同样的问题。是的，但你想吃什么晚餐？对吧？好吧，所以，你知道，你最喜欢解说的运动是什么，或者你觉得最难解说的运动是什么，你的选择是什么？我敢打赌最难的是冰球，仅仅因为所有的换人。绝对是。因为在其他每项运动中，有人控球，另一支球队在防守。是的。这显然是……
in baseball. That's the case in football. For the most part, it's the case in basketball. There are takeaways and turnovers. But in hockey, you could have a change of possession six, seven, eight times in a minute. Yeah. So to do hockey on radio to me is like impossible, because your brain can't work around, wait, wait, who has the puck? And then in a shift where, you know, your team may play Carolina once a year or Florida, you don't really know those players. Wait, who has the puck? Where is the puck? So hockey on radio, on radio is by far the toughest. TV's hard, but better. The reason it's harder on radio is because you have to say where the puck is and who's got it all the time. Exactly. With television, you can assume they can see it. Right. And in basketball, it's only 94
棒球的情况。橄榄球也是如此。大多数情况下，篮球也是如此。有抢断和失误。但在冰球中，你可能在一分钟内有六、七、八次球权转换。是的。所以对我来说，在广播里解说冰球简直是不可能的，因为你的大脑无法处理，等等，等等，谁拿球了？然后在一次换人中，你知道，你的球队可能一年只和卡罗莱纳队或佛罗里达队打一次，你并不真正了解那些球员。等等，谁拿球了？球在哪儿？所以广播里的冰球，在广播里绝对是最难的。电视解说很难，但更好。之所以在广播里更难，是因为你必须一直说球在哪里，谁拿到了球。完全正确。有了电视，你可以假设他们能看到。对。而在篮球里，只有94
feet, hockey is 200 feet. In baseball, there's a pitch and something happens after the pitch and football is a play. They are easy to describe in terms of where they are relative to the field of play. In hockey, neutral zone, just across the blue line, I mean, behind the net, I mean, you're trying to describe who has the puck. The puck is forever going to somebody else's stick. You have so many shots on goal that are blocked by 18 guys. Right. Well, only, you know, only 10 guys, obviously, with two goals. Don't you want to just tell the audience, just turn your TV on? Turn your television on. Now, is it easier for you to keep track of it by actually looking at the ice or you looking at the television like we are? What gives you the best view of tracking
英尺，冰球是200英尺。在棒球里，有一个投球，投球后会发生一些事情，橄榄球是一次进攻。它们在描述它们相对于比赛场地位置方面很容易。在冰球里，中区，刚过蓝线，我是说，在球门后面，我是说，你试图描述谁拿到了球。球永远在传给别人的球杆。你有那么多射门被18个人挡住了。对。好吧，只有，你知道，只有10个人，显然有两个守门员。你难道不想告诉观众，打开电视吗？打开你的电视。现在，通过实际看冰面来跟踪球更容易，还是像我们一样看电视更容易？什么能给你最好的视角来跟踪……
the puck? Well, I've only called, you know, probably 25 hockey games in my life, most of them in the Olympics in 80, 84 and 88 and a couple of NHL games. Including the most famous hockey game. And a couple of Stanley games. Well, yeah, I mean, that should have been the one and done. I mean, believe me, that was, you talk about I have 18 rabbits feet dangling from my pants during that game. That was, that was, that was the one game to call. But with hockey, you pretty much have to call it with your naked eye, where football, I set it up so that the monitor is right in front of me and I can look over the top of the monitor. So I can, I want to see as much as I can with the naked eye. But every time there is a shot change on television and that's what the viewer is
球？好吧，我这辈子大概只解说过25场冰球比赛，大部分是在80年、84年和88年的奥运会上，还有几场NHL比赛。包括最著名的冰球比赛。还有几场斯坦利杯比赛。好吧，是的，我是说，那应该是唯一的一次。我是说，相信我，那是，你说我有18只兔脚挂在裤子上在那场比赛中。那是，那是，那是唯一一场值得解说的比赛。但对于冰球，你几乎必须用肉眼解说，而橄榄球，我把它设置成监视器就在我面前，我可以越过监视器看。所以我可以，我想用肉眼看尽可能多的东西。但每次电视上有镜头切换，而那正是观众……
seeing, I want to know, what is he seeing in that shot change? So I've changed, I've trained myself, I've been doing this for so many years that I know how to do it. It comes to me as second nature. Baseball is so vastly different because there's so much dead time that enables you to tell all these great stories. You can get so many stories. Yeah, that's what I want to know about the stories. Coach one. No, no, I have a question, because I have a question about the art of what you do, because I believe it or not, I love watching football. I think it's like a super entertaining fast paced on great shows to watch. It is. And so what's that? Sorry, you said believe it or not. So I just said or not. Sorry, but go ahead. No, I do believe it. No, but the art of what you do
看到的，我想知道，他在那个镜头切换中看到了什么？所以我改变了，我训练了自己，我做这个已经很多年了，我知道怎么做。这对我来说成了第二天性。棒球非常不同，因为有太多的死球时间，这让你能讲所有这些伟大的故事。你可以讲很多故事。是的，这就是我想了解的故事。教练一。不，不，我有一个问题，因为我有一个关于你所做之事的艺术的问题，因为信不信由你，我喜欢看橄榄球。我觉得它就像一个超级有趣、快节奏、很棒的节目。确实是。所以那是什么？抱歉，你说信不信由你。所以我只是说或者不信。抱歉，但请继续。不，我确实相信。不，但你所做之事的艺术……
is, I assume this is why there's not a lot of Al Michaels and there's only one, because the way your brain functions to your point, what you just said, which is to fill the space, like in baseball, if there's a lot of space, or even in football, if there's like a long delay and whatever, it's kind of mind blowing that you can endlessly have this information in your head to fill the space for the audience at home. I mean, that's got to be like a skill not a lot of people have. It's a ton. I mean, I liken it really to taking a final exam every week. And in the old days, old days, 20, 30 years ago, whatever, you had maybe 15% of the information that's available to you now. What's happened now with analytics and all the rest, there are too many pieces of information.
是，我假设这就是为什么阿尔·迈克尔斯（Al Michaels）不多，只有一个的原因，因为你的大脑运作方式，正如你所说，也就是填补空白，比如在棒球里，如果有很多空间，或者即使在橄榄球里，如果有很长的延迟等等，你能在脑子里无休止地拥有这些信息来为家里的观众填补空白，这真是令人震惊。我是说，这一定是一种没多少人拥有的技能。这太重要了。我是说，我真的把它比作每周参加期末考试。在过去，过去，20、30年前，无论什么时候，你可能只有现在可用信息的15%。现在随着分析学和所有其他东西的发展，信息太多了。
So, you know, it's wonderful to start, you know, go that this the average depth of target and all that. Whoa, I think you have to back off. I don't think too many people in an audience of 20 million are sitting there concerned about the average depth of target. I mean, that is deep, deep, deep insight. Has there ever been a time where you couldn't, you didn't fill the space and you're just like, I have nothing left. Like it's so long. Like it's five minutes. I have nothing else. I have nothing else. I'm out. Right now. Yeah. But I'm interested that you said that because I was watching the game the other day, one of the playoff games and NFL playoff games. And, you know, I watch a lot of hockey and I watch a lot of European. I watch a lot of soccer. And what the,
所以，你知道，开始说这个平均目标深度等等是很棒的。哇，我觉得你得退后一点。我不认为2000万观众中有太多人坐在那里关心平均目标深度。我是说，那是很深、很深、很深的见解。有没有什么时候你不能，你没有填补空白，你只是觉得，我什么都没剩下了？就像它太长了。就像五分钟。我没有别的话了。我没有别的话了。我完了。现在。是的。但我很感兴趣你这么说，因为我前几天在看比赛，其中一场季后赛，NFL季后赛。而且，你知道，我看了很多冰球，我看了很多欧洲比赛。我看了很多足球。而……
one of the differences I know, and I was thinking like, is this because of the Madden football games or, you know, the video games, et cetera, the way that, not just in the game, but in the breakdown in between at halftime when they go back to the studio for all the networks and all the different stuff, the way they break down, they talk about the nickel defense or what these guys are doing. And they break it down in this way that I'm like, at a certain point, I'm like, hey, man, I just want to watch the game. Why are you telling me about the, the package and the guys coming into the, yeah, I don't care. Who gives a shit? I mean, it's good. It's cool. But I don't need to know. That's why I didn't become a football coach because I didn't want to have to
我所知道的区别之一，我在想，这是因为麦登（Madden）橄榄球游戏，还是，你知道，电子游戏等等，那种方式，不仅是在比赛中，而且在半场休息时的分析中，当他们回到所有电视网和所有不同东西的演播室时，他们分析的方式，他们谈论镍币防守（nickel defense）或者这些家伙在做什么。他们以这种方式分析，我心想，在某个时刻，我心想，嘿，伙计，我只想看比赛。你为什么要告诉我关于那个阵型和那些家伙进入……是的，我不在乎。谁他妈在乎？我是说，这很好。这很酷。但我不需要知道。这就是为什么我没有成为橄榄球教练，因为我不想不得不……
listen to that. Well, you're, you know, you're, you're preaching to the choir. I mean, to me, see, I believe in the less is more theory, especially on television. You're seeing it. You don't have to scream the game at people. You don't have to yell the game at people. You don't have to holler. You don't have to do it. To me, I always try to, if I can speak in captions and ellipses, you don't need full sentences to describe what people are seeing. You don't do a radio, a completely different animal. You have to describe everything because nobody can see it. On television, you can see it. And so I've always been of that mindset to try to call a game that way. Something fantastic happens. Say what you have to say with an economy of words
听那个。好吧，你，你知道，你在对牛弹琴。我是说，对我来说，看，我相信少即是多的理论，尤其是在电视上。你看到了。你不需要对人们大喊大叫比赛。你不需要对人们吼叫比赛。你不需要大声喧哗。你不需要这样做。对我来说，我总是尝试，如果我能用标题和省略号说话，你不需要完整的句子来描述人们正在看到的东西。你不需要做广播，那是完全不同的动物。你必须描述一切，因为没人能看到。在电视上，你可以看到。所以我一直有那种心态，尝试那样解说比赛。发生了一些了不起的事情。用简洁的词说出你必须说的话……
and get out of there. I mean, in Lake Placid, you know, I look into the greatest moment in American sports history. So the game ends and I had six words. Do you believe in miracles? Yes. And I'm the hell out of there for the next minute because the pictures were so good. What you do is you, you just, you, it's like throwing junk at the, at the wall to try to overwhelm or, or, or to be even in concert with those pictures. You can't let it play, let people exalt, let people enjoy what they're seeing. I think that that's why I'm first of all, I mean, obviously for years on, on Sunday night, when you started doing Sunday night football years ago, it was just the perfect way to end the week because you, you called it, it was the classiest game of the week always without
然后离开那里。我是说，在普莱西德湖（Lake Placid），你知道，我看到了美国体育史上最伟大的时刻。所以比赛结束了，我有六个字。你们相信奇迹吗？是的。接下来的那一分钟我完全闭嘴了，因为画面太好了。你所做的是你，你只是，你就像往墙上扔垃圾，试图压倒，或者，或者，或者与那些画面保持一致。你不能让它播放，让人们欢呼，让人们享受他们所看到的。我认为这就是为什么我首先，我是说，显然多年来在周日晚上，当你几年前开始做周日夜赛橄榄球时，那是结束一周的完美方式，因为你……
calling it. And now you're on Thursday nights. It's the same deal. You finally make Thursday night at night. I really like this site. Like you said, this economy of words and you don't, and you, when an incredible play happens, you're not like freaking out. You're like, what an unbelievable catch. And then that's it. Cause it's an unbelievable catch. Now, which, which, so there's two months that are the great, great sport months every year, right? Isn't it October? And then I want to say February, maybe where? Well, January, February, it's a, it's a mix because the Super Bowl is only normally in February, but all the games that lead up in January. But that, but there's also other sports that are either starting or ending in both of those two months there, that October and,
解说了它，它总是每周最优雅的比赛，而没有……解说它。现在你在周四晚上。也是一样。你终于让周四晚上变得……我真的很喜欢这个网站。就像你说的，这种简洁的词汇，你不会，而且你，当一个不可思议的进攻发生时，你不会像发疯一样。你会说，多么不可思议的接球。然后就是这样。因为它就是一个不可思议的接球。现在，哪一个，所以每年有两个月是伟大的、伟大的体育月份，对吧？不是十月吗？然后我想说二月，也许在哪里？好吧，一月，二月，这是一个混合，因为超级碗通常只在二月，但所有在一月进行的比赛。但那，但也有其他运动在两个月里开始或结束，那十月和……
and February, I think, right? Right. Basketball and hockey started in October. Right. Baseball finishes. Football is in, you know, the fourth or fifth or sixth week. Right. And college football is going full blast. Right. I know the baseball months because of the musical damn Yankees, April, May, June, July, August, September. Right. Six months. We'll be right back. SmartLess is brought to you by BetterHelp. Getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing and changing. For me, I remember this one time I was in my twenties and I had this job with this really horrible boss. And I knew he kept pushing me around and pushing me around, kind of abusing me. And I knew
二月，我想，对吧？对。篮球和冰球在十月开始。对。棒球结束。橄榄球在，你知道，第四、第五或第六周。对。大学橄榄球正在全面进行。对。我知道棒球月份，因为音乐剧《Damn Yankees》，四月、五月、六月、七月、八月、九月。对。六个月。我们马上回来。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。了解自己可能是一个终生的过程，尤其是因为我们总是在成长和变化。对我来说，我记得有一次我在二十多岁的时候，我有一份工作，老板非常糟糕。我知道他一直欺负我，一直欺负我，有点虐待我。我知道……
that it was at that time I had to grow. I had to practice self-care. And in order to do that, I had to become self-aware. Right. So I knew enough to, to, to make myself feel better in the moment. And I pushed back and I created boundaries for myself. And that was a huge turning point for myself. I grew and I changed from that moment when I actually confronted him and I said, I can't take this anymore. I need to create boundaries. It's me or the job I told myself. So I chose me and it changed my life. I grew immensely from that moment. And when I got into therapy, it gave me the tools to even create more boundaries and realize that communicating those boundaries was just as important. So therapy is all about deepening your self-awareness and
那是时候我必须成长了。我必须练习自我保健。为了做到这一点，我必须变得有自我意识。对。所以我知道足够多，能让自己在当下感觉更好。我反击了，我为自己设定了界限。那对我来说是一个巨大的转折点。我成长了，我从那一刻起就改变了，当我真正面对他并说，我受够了。我需要设定界限。要么是我，要么是这份工作，我告诉自己。所以我选择了自己，它改变了我的生活。从那一刻起，我成长了很多。当我开始接受治疗时，它给了我工具来创造更多的界限，并意识到沟通这些界限同样重要。所以治疗就是关于加深你的自我意识和……
understanding because sometimes we don't know what we want or why we react the way we do until we talk through things. Right. BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp h-e-l-p.com slash smartlist. Our thanks to ZipRecruiter for their support. You know what?
理解，因为有时我们不知道我们想要什么，或者为什么我们会有这样的反应，直到我们谈论事情。对。BetterHelp为你联系一位持证治疗师，无论你在哪里，都能带你踏上那段自我发现的旅程。所以如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。它完全在线，设计得方便、灵活，适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。用BetterHelp发现你的潜力。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp h-e-l-p.com/smartlist。感谢ZipRecruiter的支持。你知道吗？
If I was to start a new business out of all the businesses I could think of, the one that would make most sense for me is a lemonade stand but tuna fish sandwiches. Like you drive by, I'll put my little cup out. You put, you know, a donation of your choice and you get a fresh tuna sandwich. And if you like it the way I like it with lots and lots and lots and lots of mayo in it. And I want to do it in the summer months when it's hot. Who's in? Whether you're starting a new business like a tuna stand or growing one, if you want it to be successful, you need the most talented people on your team. That's where ZipRecruiter comes in. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. ZipRecruiter's
如果我要从我能想到的所有生意中开始一项新生意，对我来说最有意义的是一个卖金枪鱼三明治的柠檬水摊。就像你开车经过，我会把我的小杯子放出来。你放，你知道，你选择的捐款，你就能得到一个新鲜的金枪鱼三明治。如果你喜欢我喜欢的那种，里面有很多很多很多很多蛋黄酱。我想在夏天天气热的时候做。谁加入？无论你是像金枪鱼摊一样开始一项新生意，还是在发展一项生意，如果你想成功，你需要团队中最有才华的人。这就是ZipRecruiter发挥作用的地方。现在你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartlist免费试用。ZipRecruiter的……
powerful matching technology finds highly qualified candidates for a wide range of roles. Got your eye on one or two people who'd be perfect for your job? ZipRecruiter lets you send them a personal invite so they're more likely to apply. ZipRecruiter also offers attention-grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility like remote, training-provided, urgent, and more to really help your job stand out. And speaking of standing out, who's that I spy little Jessica and Ronald across the street handing out tuna sandwiches? Way to go, guys! Way to go! No! Let ZipRecruiter fill all your roles with the right candidates. Four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself! Go to
强大的匹配技术为各种角色找到高素质的候选人。看中了一两个非常适合你工作的人？ZipRecruiter让你给他们发送个人邀请，这样他们更有可能申请。ZipRecruiter还提供吸引注意力的标签，说明工作的灵活性，如远程、提供培训、紧急等等，真正帮助你的工作脱颖而出。说到脱颖而出，那是谁，我看到街对面小杰西卡和罗纳德在分发金枪鱼三明治？干得好，伙计们！干得好！不！让ZipRecruiter用合适的候选人填补你所有的角色。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四在第一天内就得到了高质量的候选人。自己看看吧！去……
this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash s-m-a-r-t-l-e-s-s. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. Smartlist is supported by Benjamin Moore. Everything has their own style and flavor for things, and luckily, Benjamin Moore's got over 3,500 premium colors that make it easier to express yourself. Maybe Brown Wenge, or some people say Brown Wenge, is a great match for your room where 1800s austerity is key. Or Perfectly Pesto Green works wonderfully with your office that has approximately 92% plants. Maybe it comes down to how your life is going in long-term mood and outlook. Benjamin Moore makes it easy to switch things around to match up with your life. Speaking of life,
这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。再说一遍，是ziprecruiter.com/s-m-a-r-t-l-e-s-s。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。Smartlist由Benjamin Moore支持。每件事都有自己的风格和品味，幸运的是，Benjamin Moore有超过3500种优质颜色，让你更容易表达自己。也许棕色Wenge，或者有些人说棕色Wenge，非常适合你的房间，那里1800年代的朴素是关键。或者完美的香蒜绿（Perfectly Pesto Green）与你的办公室搭配得非常好，那里有大约92%的植物。也许这取决于你的生活在长期情绪和前景方面如何。Benjamin Moore让你很容易切换颜色来匹配你的生活。说到生活，
isn't life golden? Like Benjamin Moore's Golden Straw, number 2152-50. It's not called Benjamin Less. It's called Benjamin Moore because Benjamin Moore paints higher quality because you've done well for yourself. Many things in your life are of higher quality, like your house, your car, your personal belongings. Of course, the paint you use falls into this too. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. Save 15% off your next paint on sample purchase at BenjaminMore.com using code SMARTLESS. That's BenjaminMore.com code SMARTLESS. Back to the show. Now, what stadium do you love visiting the most and what city do you love visiting the most? Well, as a homebody, there's no greater game for me to do than a raider or a charger game.
生活不是金色的吗？就像Benjamin Moore的Golden Straw，编号2152-50。它不叫Benjamin Less。它叫Benjamin Moore，因为Benjamin Moore的油漆质量更高，因为你为自己做得很好。你生活中的许多事情质量更高，比如你的房子、你的车、你的个人物品。当然，你使用的油漆也属于这一类。Benjamin Moore油漆只在当地拥有的商店出售。在BenjaminMore.com上使用代码SMARTLESS，下次购买油漆样品可节省15%。那是BenjaminMore.com代码SMARTLESS。回到节目。现在，你最喜欢访问哪个体育场，你最喜欢访问哪个城市？好吧，作为一个宅男，对我来说没有比突袭者队或闪电队比赛更好的比赛了。
Right. Because I can go down to the 405. Or rams. You said raiders, rams. Well, the raiders at the rams. That's what I meant to say. Raiders at rams. There goes my memory already at shot. You see, it's the off-season. Off-season. You're going to Vegas soon. Yeah. Right. I'm thinking about, of course I am. Are the A's going to move to Vegas? They probably should. That has been going on for 30 years. Oh, really? 30 years. It's a horrible ballpark. It's the worst ever. Yeah. The worst ever. The old one. The oldest. And they've been talking about this for years. Yeah. And, you know, it's kind of funny how the Giants, and remember, I did, I've left the Reds to do the Giants in 74, 5, and 6. And that ballpark was the worst ever. Candlestick Park. Just a complete garbage
对。因为我可以去405公路。或者公羊队。你说突袭者，公羊。好吧，突袭者对公羊。我本来想说那个。突袭者对公羊。我的记忆力已经不行了。你看，这是休赛期。休赛期。你很快要去维加斯。是的。对。我在想，我当然在想。运动家队（A's）要搬到维加斯吗？他们可能应该搬。这已经持续了30年了。哦，真的吗？30年。那是一个糟糕的球场。这是有史以来最差的。是的。旧的那个。最老的。他们已经谈论这个很多年了。是的。而且，你知道，巨人队很有趣，记住，我离开红人队去解说巨人队是在74、75和76年。那个球场是有史以来最差的。烛台公园（Candlestick Park）。简直就是一堆垃圾……
dump. And the Giants threatened twice to move out. Will might remember to Toronto. They were going to go to Toronto in 1976. Oh, my God. Labasse was going to buy the team the brewery before the Blue Jays got the expansion franchise. Wow. I did not know that. There's something Will didn't know. So they almost did. They were saved by a guy named Bob Lurie. And then in 93, St. Petersburg came in before the Tampa Bay Rays got their team. And they almost bought the team. And it was saved by a guy named Peter McGowan from Safeway Stores. Wow. Then they went ahead and they built this stadium in downtown San Francisco, which is beautiful. Fantastic. You have a view of the Bay Bridge. It's, it changed everything. They went from the worst stadium
垃圾场。巨人队两次威胁要搬走。威尔可能记得去多伦多。他们本来要在1976年去多伦多。哦，天哪。拉巴斯（Labasse）本来要买下这支球队，那家啤酒厂，在蓝鸟队获得扩张特许经营权之前。哇。我不知道。有些威尔不知道的事。所以他们差点就去了。他们被一个叫鲍勃·卢里（Bob Lurie）的人救了。然后在93年，圣彼得堡在坦帕湾光芒队获得球队之前进来了。他们差点买下这支球队。它被一个来自Safeway Stores的彼得·麦高恩（Peter McGowan）救了。哇。然后他们继续前进，他们在旧金山市中心建了这个体育场，非常漂亮。太棒了。你可以看到海湾大桥。它，改变了一切。他们从最差的体育场……
where you couldn't draw flies to the best stadium where this sold out every night. This was Pac-Bell and now Levi's, right? Well, whatever it is, it's a, they changed the, they changed, I can't, I can't keep track of the right. So with that, is that your, do you think that's the best stadium currently right now? It's all a matter of, you know, choice and you can argue it. But yeah, I mean, it's, it's, it's in the converse. It's in the conversation is a place you love to watch a baseball game. Right. And great. Let's put it that way. Those garlic fries, right? Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Whatever it is, a quiche. Now, what, what the newest one is what SoFi, right? And I feel like there's another one being built too. Oh, anyone? What do you think
连苍蝇都吸引不了，变成了最好的体育场，每晚都售罄。这是Pac-Bell，现在是Levi's，对吧？好吧，无论它是什么，它是一个，他们改变了，我不能，我不能跟踪那个。所以，那是你的，你认为那是目前最好的体育场吗？这完全是关于，你知道，选择，你可以争论它。但是的，我是说，它，它，它在对话中是一个你喜欢看棒球比赛的地方。对。而且很棒。我们就这么说吧。那些大蒜薯条，对吧？哦，是的。哦，是的。无论它是什么，乳蛋饼。现在，什么，最新的一个是SoFi，对吧？我觉得还有另一个也在建。哦，有人吗？你觉得……
of the, like the Sofis in these stadiums, these incredible sort of like shopping malls that host sporting events? I think Sofi is terrific. I think they did a fantastic job there. And of course, you know, living in the city as we do, we had old and decrepit facilities. The Coliseum has been around 100 years. The Rose Bowl has been around around for more than 100 years. Dodger Stadium has held up a Dodger Stadium is almost 60 years old. Third oldest. We needed a, we needed a facility and, and Stan Crocky built it. And, and this is how all of these stadiums are now being built these days, because they try to take all of the land around it and then build up, you know, either retail or housing or other, you know, or other entertainment venues. I mean, you go down
像SoFi这些体育场，这些举办体育赛事的不可思议的购物中心怎么样？我觉得SoFi太棒了。我觉得他们在那里做得非常出色。当然，你知道，像我们一样住在城市里，我们有陈旧破败的设施。体育馆（Coliseum）已经存在100年了。玫瑰碗（Rose Bowl）已经存在超过100年了。道奇体育场（Dodger Stadium）一直保持着，道奇体育场快60岁了。第三古老。我们需要一个，我们需要一个设施，而且，斯坦·克伦克（Stan Crocky）建造了它。而且，这就是现在所有这些体育场建造的方式，因为他们试图利用周围所有的土地，然后建造，你知道，要么是零售，要么是住房，或者其他，你知道，或者其他娱乐场所。我是说，你现在去……
to Anglewood right now, it's kind of crazy. You got Sofi and they can do not only concerts in Sofi, they have a smaller addition to that building. We can do them. The form still exists across the parking lot. Steve Bomber is building a place for the Clippers across Century Boulevard. They're going to have concerts. So I mean, that's going to become like, right, you know, the entertainment, I don't want to say the entertainment capital of the world, but boy, oh boy, there's going to be something going on there every night. Looking forward to the traffic. Now, what happens when you're spoken like a true Angelino? Now, what happens when you are, when you're calling a game for a team that you love? Who's,
英格尔伍德（Anglewood），这有点疯狂。你有SoFi，他们不仅可以在SoFi举办音乐会，他们还有那个建筑的一个较小的附属建筑。我们可以做。论坛球馆（The Forum）仍然存在于停车场对面。史蒂夫·鲍尔默（Steve Bomber）正在世纪大道（Century Boulevard）对面为快船队建造一个地方。他们将举办音乐会。所以我是说，那将变得像，对，你知道，娱乐，我不想说世界娱乐之都，但天哪，天哪，那里每晚都会有事情发生。期待交通。现在，当你……说得像个真正的天使之城人。现在，当你，当你为你喜欢的球队解说比赛时，谁是……
who's, who's your, who's your favorite sports team? I mean, you, you, is it, is it the Reds? Because you started back with them? No. No, I have an affinity with, remember the Dodgers were my team as a kid. Right. And we're until I got the, the Reds job. I had the Reds for three years. I had the Giants for three years. You know, I'm, I'm really kind of an impassive observer. Maybe in my heart of hearts, I want to see one win over the other, but I'm really not a fan fan, except as Will knows, and since they have nothing to do with it, the Kings. When I go to a hockey game, I am all in on the Kings. And when the Kings won the cup in 12 and 14, and Will, it's an amazing thing when your team gets to lift the cup. Just in case you're wondering, I know.
谁是，谁是，谁是你最喜欢的运动队？我是说，你，你，是红人队吗？因为你从他们开始？不。不。我对，记住道奇队是我小时候的球队。对。直到我得到红人队的工作。我为红人队工作了三年。我为巨人队工作了三年。你知道，我真的有点像一个冷静的观察者。也许在我内心深处，我想看到一支球队赢过另一支，但我真的不是一个粉丝，除了威尔知道的，而且因为他们与此无关，国王队（Kings）。当我去看冰球比赛时，我全力支持国王队。当国王队在12年和14年赢得奖杯时，威尔，当你的球队举起奖杯时，这是一件令人惊奇的事情。以防你想知道，我知道。
I was, by the way, I was there when the Kings won. You know, I'm such a fan in general. So I was there. I wanted to burn it into my memory so that I can get ready for what was to come. But you don't have to, but you don't have to give extra thought to hiding your bias when you're calling a game, right? You're, you're, you're too much of a pro for that. You must have. You can't. Yeah. I mean, I'm really, the only thing I'm rooting for when I go out to do a game is drama. Right. Yeah. I want, I want drama. I want a game to go to the end of the game. I want, I want there to be in a lot of excitement. I want there to be. And I love how unapologetic you are too, when there isn't drama, because, because you know,
顺便说一下，国王队赢的时候我在那儿。你知道，我总体上是一个粉丝。所以我当时在那儿。我想把它刻在我的记忆里，这样我就可以为即将到来的事情做好准备。但你不必，但你不必在解说比赛时额外考虑隐藏你的偏见，对吧？你太专业了，不会那样。你一定有。你不能。我是说，我真的，当我出去解说比赛时，我唯一支持的是戏剧性。对。是的。我想要，我想要戏剧性。我想要一场比赛打到最后。我想要，我想要有很多兴奋。我想要有。而且我喜欢你那种毫不掩饰的态度，当没有戏剧性的时候，因为，因为你知道……
the audience knows that there's no drama going on right now. And you're not insulting their intelligence by pressing and forcing some drama in that you just like, well, this game sucks. And it makes it worth watching. Yeah. No, no, no, no, you're selling a bad bill of goods if you're trying to do that. Fans, no, they know when the game is good. They know when the game is great. They know when the game is average. They know when the game is terrible. And I know, you know, I got, there was a lot of talk about the way I did the Denver Indianapolis game, which was a very bad football game in week four last year. Terrible. Terrible. I mean, every part of the game was awful. Tons of penalties, no scoring. And, you know, I just,
观众知道现在没有戏剧性发生。你没有通过强行制造一些戏剧性来侮辱他们的智商，你只是说，好吧，这场比赛烂透了。这让它值得一看。是的。不，不，不，不，如果你试图那样做，你就是在卖劣质商品。粉丝，知道，他们知道比赛什么时候好。他们知道比赛什么时候棒。他们知道比赛什么时候一般。他们知道比赛什么时候糟糕。而且我知道，你知道，我，关于我解说丹佛对印第安纳波利斯那场比赛的方式有很多讨论，那是去年第四周一场非常糟糕的橄榄球比赛。糟糕。糟糕。我是说，比赛的每一部分都很糟糕。大量的犯规，没有得分。而且，你知道，我只是……
I couldn't help myself at the end of the game when Fred Godelli, our producer, punched up a shot of the crowd is leaving before overtime. And, and then there was a shot, there was a shot from outside of the stadium in Denver and you saw another thousand people streaming into the parking lot. And, uh, my partner Kirk Herb Street, who had only worked with a few weeks, you know, and Kirk was still learning my sense of humor, said, I can't believe, you know, they're leaving. It's overtime. I said, they'd seen enough. Sometimes you just got to beat the traffic. I mean, which I think, which I think, I think reflected the view of the fans at that point. What are you gonna say? Exactly. That's why we love you. Al, you've called games with so many of the great, you've had so
在比赛结束时，当我们的制片人弗雷德·戈德利（Fred Godelli）切到一个观众在加时赛前离开的镜头时，我忍不住了。而且，有一个从丹佛体育场外拍摄的镜头，你看到又有几千人涌向停车场。而且，我的搭档柯克·赫布斯特里特（Kirk Herb Street），他只和我合作了几周，你知道，柯克还在学习我的幽默感，说，我不敢相信，你知道，他们要走了。这是加时赛。我说，他们已经看够了。有时你就是得避开交通高峰。我是说，我认为，我认为这反映了当时粉丝的观点。你要说什么？完全正确。这就是我们爱你的原因。阿尔，你和这么多伟大的球员一起解说过比赛，你已经有了这么多……
many great co-conspirators with you in the booth over the years. I mean, the greatest. And I don't want to ask you to pick favorites, but if you, if you have any highlight, highlight guys or moments over the years that just, you know, I don't know. I mean, you've had the greatest. I don't know, you know, yeah. Well, you've had them all or they've, they've all learned something from you. Um, you know, I mean, who's, who's had more, more partners broadcasting than you? Probably no one. Well, I probably, I probably had over a hundred beats. I've done things like motorcycles on ice and all that other stuff that, you know, are done with different people. But yeah, but I never got to do a game with Vince Scully, but I, you know, heard Vinny thousands of times.
多年来，你在直播间里有很多很棒的合作搭档。我是说，最棒的。我不想让你选出最喜欢的，但如果你有多年来印象最深刻的搭档或时刻，你知道，我不知道。我是说，你合作过的都是最顶尖的。我不知道，你知道，是的。好吧，你和他们所有人都合作过，或者他们都从你身上学到了东西。嗯，你知道，我是说，谁的广播搭档比你更多？可能没人了。嗯，我大概，我大概有过一百多个搭档。我做过像冰上摩托车之类的节目，你知道，都是和不同的人一起做的。但是是的，我从来没能和文·斯卡利（Vin Scully）一起解说比赛，但我，你知道，听过文尼（Vinny）无数次了。
I loved Kurt Gowdy, who was back in the 70s. And I got to do the World Series with Kurt on NBCBs when the Reds won the pennant. And I'm there in those years, the local team's number one announcer, which I was, got to work with Kurt on the World Series. So here I am, a kid, and I'm doing the World Series with Kurt Gowdy. And we're coming on the air, uh, you know, on, in October of 1972, Saturday afternoon, it's, it's the Reds and the A's in the World Series. And guys, when the camera came on and I'm sitting with Kurt, and it's a one shot of Kurt, and they got to pan out and, uh, uh, and bring me in. And all I could think in my brain was, please God, please God, when I opened my mouth, let air come out. That's how nervous,
我喜欢库尔特·高迪（Kurt Gowdy），那是70年代的事了。当红人队赢得锦旗时，我有幸在NBC和库尔特一起解说世界大赛。那几年我作为当地球队的头号播音员，我有机会和库尔特一起解说世界大赛。所以当时我还是个孩子，却在和库尔特·高迪一起解说世界大赛。那是1972年10月的一个周六下午，是红人队对阵运动家队的世界大赛。伙计们，当摄像机打开，我和库尔特坐在一起时，镜头先是库尔特一个人的特写，然后他们拉远镜头，把我带入画面。我脑子里唯一能想到的就是，求求上帝，求求上帝，当我开口时，让声音发出来吧。我当时就是那么紧张，
that's how nervous I was. But sure enough, and then once he introduced me and away we went, and then there's like, wow, this is the greatest thing of all time. God, you can take me now, but at least wait until a week from Wednesday, Sunday, which, you know, oh man, that was out of all of those people that, that you've, you've announced with their called games with, is there one moment that stands out with us? Is either like the funniest, like mishap, or just the funniest person that you've called a game with? Well, yeah, I mean, I just, I just wanted to go to a couple of partners that want to mention that. And then I got the, that, that funny story for you. But Ken Dryden, who of course was an iconic hockey figure, the great Ken, Ken and I did
我当时就是那么紧张。但确实，一旦他介绍了我，我们就开始了，然后感觉就像，哇，这是有史以来最棒的事情。上帝，你现在可以带我走了，但至少等到下周三或周日吧，你知道，哦天哪，在所有你合作过、一起解说比赛的人中，有没有哪个时刻让你印象深刻？比如最有趣的失误，或者和你一起解说比赛的最有趣的人？嗯，是的，我是说，我只是想提几个搭档。然后我有一个有趣的故事要讲给你听。但是肯·德莱顿（Ken Dryden），他当然是冰球界的标志性人物，伟大的肯，我和肯做过
three Olympics together. He was with the, the miracle on ice was great. I love, love, love. By the way, Al, Al, do you want to know one thing quickly about Ken Dryden? Here's a stat. Went to Cornell, uh, was drafted by the, by the Canadians, by the Habs, but so he joined the Habs in the spring after Cornell's hockey season, goes to the playoffs, wins the Stanley Cup, and wins the consmith MVP of this playoffs before he's played a regular season game, and then wins the Calder next year for rookie of the year. The resident Montreal during that period. I saw Ken Dryden with my own eyes as a rookie at the forum. Yes, I did. So there he was. Eight years later, we'd be together. I did baseball with Jim Palmer and Tim McCarver. Loved
三届奥运会。他参与的“冰上奇迹”非常棒。我爱，爱，爱。顺便问一下，阿尔，阿尔，你想知道关于肯·德莱顿的一件事吗？这里有个数据。他去了康奈尔大学，被加拿大人队（Habs）选中，在康奈尔冰球赛季结束后，他春天加入了加拿大人队，进入季后赛，赢得了斯坦利杯，并在他打常规赛之前就赢得了季后赛的康恩·斯迈思奖（MVP），第二年又赢得了卡尔德奖（年度最佳新秀）。那段时间他住在蒙特利尔。我亲眼见过肯·德莱顿作为新秀在论坛球馆打球。是的，我见过。所以他就在那里。八年后，我们在一起工作了。我和吉姆·帕尔默（Jim Palmer）和蒂姆·麦卡弗（Tim McCarver）一起解说棒球。我很喜欢
it. I had football with Frank Gifford and Dan Deardor for years. Then I had football with, with John Madden for seven years. I had Chris Collins for 30 years. I mean, I have had some fantastic partners, but, but Sean has the question about funny, Bob Uker. Bob Uker may have been the second funniest man of all time, topped only by Don Rickles. And we can totally, and Don was a great friend and loved that. Never did a game with Don, but we loved him. Mr. Belvedere. Anyway, so Bob, Bob Uker. I did an episode of Belvedere, by the way, with him. Here we go. Oh my God, he was fantastic. So Uker and I are doing a game in, in Houston with Howard Cosell, another one, I forgot to mention, the one and only. And we are, we're trying to, you know, talk Howard out
它。我和弗兰克·吉福德（Frank Gifford）和丹·迪尔多夫（Dan Dierdorf）一起解说橄榄球多年。然后我和约翰·马登（John Madden）一起解说橄榄球七年。我和克里斯·柯林斯沃斯（Cris Collinsworth）合作了30年。我是说，我有一些非常棒的搭档，但是，肖恩有个关于有趣的问题，鲍勃·尤克（Bob Uker）。鲍勃·尤克可能是有史以来第二有趣的人，仅次于唐·里克斯（Don Rickles）。我们可以完全，唐也是个伟大的朋友，我很喜欢他。从来没和唐一起解说比赛，但我们很爱他。贝尔维德先生（Mr. Belvedere）。总之，鲍勃·尤克。顺便说一下，我还和他一起拍过一集《贝尔维德先生》。开始了。哦天哪，他太棒了。所以尤克和我正在休斯顿解说一场比赛，还有霍华德·科塞尔（Howard Cosell），另一个我忘了提的，独一无二的霍华德。我们正试图，你知道，劝说霍华德
of what Howard was, was talking about, because Howard always thought baseball was such a simple game. They make it so complicated, but Howard really never understood the game. And Howard, in this game, is calling for a butt in a situation where nobody in the world, the manager, if he called for a bun in that situation, would get fired. Faces loaded, no outs. And whatever it was, it was just a ridiculous situation. And Uker, Uker and I are trying to, you know, kind of ease, ease, ease it down a little bit from where Howard's going, you know, and Uke says, well, Howard, you know, I understand what you're saying. He really didn't. But, you know, you got this thing and that thing and he's in the bullpen and blah, blah, blah. He reads, he writes about eight examples.
放弃他正在谈论的话题，因为霍华德总是认为棒球是一项简单的运动。他们把它搞得太复杂了，但霍华德其实从来没真正理解这项运动。在这场比赛中，霍华德在那种情况下呼吁短打，世界上没有任何经理会在那种情况下要求短打，如果他这么做了，他会被解雇的。满垒，无人出局。无论是什么情况，那简直太荒谬了。尤克和我正试图，你知道，稍微缓和一下霍华德的观点，你知道，尤克说，好吧，霍华德，你知道，我明白你在说什么。他其实并不明白。但是，你知道，你有这个那个，他在牛棚里，等等等等。他读了大约八个例子。
So Howard, you can picture Howard. Howard says, he's going to play with Uker now. He goes, okay, Uke, I get your point. You don't have to be so truculent. You do know what truculent means, don't you? And without hesitation, Uker says, Howard, of course, if you had a truck and I borrowed it, it would be a truculent, right? That was Bob Uker. And then the other one was, remember, baseballs are horse hides, right? Or there used to be none of the cow hides with their horse hides in those years. And we're talking about Charlie Finley wanted to have the alert orange baseball. Fans could see it easier, much like the tennis ball. And this became, you know, a topic of conversation. So one night, Uker and I are doing a game and it's an eight run game or
所以霍华德，你可以想象霍华德的样子。霍华德说，他现在要和尤克开玩笑了。他说，好吧，尤克，我明白你的意思了。你不必那么好斗（truculent）。你知道好斗是什么意思，对吧？尤克毫不犹豫地说，霍华德，当然，如果你有一辆卡车（truck），我借了它，它就是好斗的（truck-ulent），对吧？这就是鲍勃·尤克。还有一件事，记得吗，棒球是马皮做的，对吧？或者那些年里，它们不是牛皮，而是马皮。我们当时在谈论查理·芬利（Charlie Finley）想要那种亮橙色的棒球。球迷们可以更容易看到它，就像网球一样。这成了，你知道，一个谈话话题。所以有一天晚上，尤克和我正在解说一场比赛，那是一场八分差距的比赛，或者
it's, you know, it's over. And we start to fill time talking about that. And Uker says, well, you know, at the end of the day, that could never be done. And I said, well, why not? He said, you couldn't find enough diseased horses. So I mean, this was, this was Bob. This was Uke. Are you talking to anybody specific in your mind when you're calling a game? Or are you just, or are you kind of having a conversation with your, with your, with your color announcer? You know, do you, or do you think that you're talking to all of America? Like, is there a perspective that, that, that you're in when you're, when you're, when you're talking? You know, that is a great question, which I've thought about a lot. And I still
它，你知道，已经结束了。我们开始填补时间谈论那个话题。尤克说，好吧，你知道，归根结底，那是不可能做到的。我说，好吧，为什么不呢？他说，你找不到足够的患病马匹。所以我是说，这就是鲍勃。这就是尤克。你在解说比赛时，心里是在和谁说话吗？还是你只是，或者你是在和你的色彩解说员进行对话？你知道，你，或者你认为你在和全美国说话？就像，当你说话时，你处于什么样的视角？你知道，这是一个很好的问题，我思考过很多。但我仍然
don't have the exact answer to it because there are times when you don't, it's not like you have a megaphone and you're talking to a hundred million people. You really have to think more in line of I'm talking to one person. And I've tried to think that way because I've done 11 Super Bowls and I know you have an audience over a hundred million people watching and you can choke to death when you come on the earth thinking about, I'm talking to a hundred million people. But I try to think to myself, I'm talking to one. And I'm also saying to myself, you play mind tricks here, you have 330 million people who live in the United States of America, a hundred million are watching, 230 million don't give a damn. Right. Yeah, half full or half empty. Mine games. Now,
没有确切的答案，因为有时候你并不是拿着扩音器在和一亿人说话。你真的必须更多地考虑我在和一个人的对话。我试着那样想，因为我解说过11届超级碗，我知道你有一亿多观众在看，当你想到我在和一亿人说话时，你可能会紧张得窒息。但我试着对自己说，我在和一个说话。我也在对自己说，你在这里玩心理游戏，美国有3.3亿人，一亿人在看，2.3亿人根本不在乎。对。是的，半满还是半空。心理游戏。现在，
do you get to keep all those handsome clothes you get to wear? I mean, every time they put the trim on you guys in the, you look like Will Arnett up there with the Bruno Cuccinelli and the fucking Laura Piana. I mean, you guys are wearing like $3,000 outfits every day. You don't get to take it home. No, because I buy my own clothes because the clothes they gave us for the last couple of years have been not, you know, look like Army Navy fire sale surplus. So I'm not going that way. So you're packing a nice garment bag every game. I'm paying. What can I tell you, man? You know, that's it. I go out and I buy a couple of, you know, sport coats and away I go. Al, speaking of sport coats, the one thing I want, you can't make this promise to me,
你那些帅气的衣服可以留着吗？我是说，每次他们给你们穿上那些衣服，你们看起来就像威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）穿着布鲁内洛·库奇内利（Brunello Cucinelli）和该死的诺悠翩（Loro Piana）。我是说，你们每天都穿着价值3000美元的行头。你不能带回家吗？不，因为我自己买衣服，因为过去几年他们给我们的衣服看起来不像，你知道，看起来像陆海军剩余物资甩卖。所以我不会那样做。所以你每场比赛都要打包一个漂亮的服装袋？我自己付钱。我能说什么呢，伙计？你知道，就是这样。我出去买几件，你知道，运动外套，然后我就出发了。阿尔，说到运动外套，有一件事我想要，你不能向我保证，
but I'd love to come over one day and just you keep all the blazers with the various insignias from all the networks and stuff in the wide world to sports over the years. Well, the yellow, Monday night football one. Oh, I love those. No, I had one, I had one yellow one. We tried to find it. We were going to go to a, you know, a Halloween party or something. And I couldn't fish it out of the, out of the closet. Imagine that you're at a Halloween party and Al Michael shows up on Monday there. We looked like a bunch of canaries. Best. Who's got the best dog or meal? Yeah. The best hot dog. Yeah. The best hot dog. Dodger Stadium sells the most. People will be surprised to hear. Frankly, to be honest with you, the old, the old dodger dogs
但我很想有一天去看看，你保留了多年来来自所有电视网和体育世界的所有带有各种徽章的西装外套。嗯，黄色的，周一橄榄球之夜的那件。哦，我喜欢那些。不，我有一件，我有一件黄色的。我们试着找它。我们本来要去参加一个，你知道，万圣节派对之类的。但我没能从衣柜里把它翻出来。想象一下，你在万圣节派对上，阿尔·迈克尔斯（Al Michaels）穿着周一橄榄球之夜的衣服出现。我们看起来像一群金丝雀。最好。谁有最好的热狗或餐点？是的。最好的热狗。是的。最好的热狗。道奇体育场卖得最多。人们听到这个会很惊讶。坦率地说，老实说，老道奇热狗
were fantastic. Thank you. You're okay right now. Thank you. Oh, as, as Vinny would, as Vinny would say, farmer John, farmer John, old beef wieners, Eastern most in quality, Western most in flavor. I make a good hot dog. I cut it up and put it in a mac and cheese. It's good. Yeah. Do you really? Yeah. Sometimes. What about us? You know, to me, there's nothing better than a big, juicy steak. Nothing. Yeah. Well, what's stadium service? You know, it's, it's well known. I don't, I don't eat vegetables. I just eat, you know, I eat meat. I eat meat. I eat chicken. I eat fish. You don't eat any vegetables. Some starches. Zero. What's the matter with you? Zero. I'm, I'm notorious for that. I've heard that about you. Yeah. No. You and Sean are going to get along
非常棒。谢谢。你现在没事了。谢谢。哦，正如文尼会说的，农夫约翰（Farmer John），农夫约翰，老牛肉热狗，东部品质最好，西部风味最浓。我做的热狗很好吃。我把它切碎放进通心粉和奶酪里。很好吃。是的。你真的这么做吗？是的。有时候。我们呢？你知道，对我来说，没有什么比一块大而多汁的牛排更好的了。没有什么。是的。好吧，体育场服务是什么？你知道，众所周知。我不，我不吃蔬菜。我只吃，你知道，我吃肉。我吃肉。我吃鸡肉。我吃鱼。你不吃任何蔬菜。一些淀粉。零。你怎么了？零。我在这方面很有名。我听说过你。是的。不。你和肖恩会相处得
marvellous. Why don't you eat vegetables? I hate them. I don't like to look at them. I don't like to smell them. Hang on. A gun to your head. You have to have one vegetable. Which one would it be if you had to have one? A steak. A steak. Wait, wait, wait. Al, I bet you, I bet you I'm right at the, Al, would you eat, would you eat a wedge salad like at the Palm? Would you have the wedge? Oh hell no. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Your body's got to be so clean. Thank you. You could, you could probably sneak something into the middle of pasta maybe. You're right. Some tomato sauce. Maybe. You would, you would, but that's a fruit. Well, I like tomatoes. I like tomatoes are fruit and, and I'll eat potatoes. That's a starch,
非常融洽。你为什么不吃蔬菜？我讨厌它们。我不喜欢看它们。我不喜欢闻它们。等等。如果用枪指着你的头。你必须吃一种蔬菜。如果必须吃一种，会是哪一种？牛排。牛排。等等，等等，等等。阿尔，我敢打赌，我敢打赌我是对的，阿尔，你会吃像棕榈餐厅（The Palm）那样的楔形沙拉吗？你会吃那个楔形沙拉吗？哦，见鬼不。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。你的身体一定很干净。谢谢。你可能可以在意大利面里偷偷放点什么。你是对的。一些番茄酱。也许。你会，你会，但那是水果。好吧，我喜欢番茄。我喜欢番茄是水果，而且，我会吃土豆。那是淀粉，
but everything else. Now, the only time I came close is Michelle DeFoyer, our sideline reporter for years. We're in Baltimore one night. We had a couple of nights off. We had a long day and it's about, you know, four or five martinis and she sneaks me some French fries, which turned out to be Brussels sprouts that were so deep fried, they might as well have been. So I actually put that down into my body and, you know, that's the closest I've ever come in. Trojan horse. The Trojan horse. By the way, that's the second Trojan horse I've heard during the podcast. It's the Trojan horse episode. I'm here for, I'm here for quality control. You know that. Well, Jason, Jason, Jason is, and his wife are, they're, they're like living up in this castle
但其他一切。现在，我唯一接近的一次是米歇尔·德福耶（Michelle Tafoya），我们多年的场边记者。有一天晚上我们在巴尔的摩。我们有几天休息时间。我们度过了漫长的一天，喝了大约四五杯马提尼，她偷偷给我一些炸薯条，结果发现是抱子甘蓝，炸得太透了，它们可能就是。所以我真的把它放进我的身体里，你知道，这是我最接近的一次。特洛伊木马。特洛伊木马。顺便说一下，这是我在播客中听到的第二个特洛伊木马。这是特洛伊木马那一集。我是为了质量控制而来的。你知道的。好吧，杰森，杰森，杰森和他的妻子，他们，他们就像住在这座城堡里
and they, and they've eliminated all food and all they do is think about is eating nuts and cardboard and such. And so I said, Jason, you heard the story. I sent him all this junk food because I know how much he loves. He'll come into my house every once in a while. He'll walk in and he'll go straight to the pantry and he starts going, who bought this? As he's eating it. I just shoveled as much junk as I can get in. And I'm like, I got two, I got three boys here who live here, four actually. So anyway, um, Al, boy, we can just talk to you forever. It's like hanging out with it. Well, it is hanging out with an old buddy. We really appreciate your time. Pick this up. I'm gonna go afterwards. It's really cool to meet you, Al. Al, you're the best.
一样，他们消除了所有食物，他们所想的只是吃坚果和纸板之类的东西。所以我说，杰森，你听过这个故事。我寄给他所有这些垃圾食品，因为我知道他有多喜欢。他偶尔会来我家。他会走进来，直接走向食品储藏室，然后开始说，谁买了这些？当他吃的时候。我只是尽可能多地塞进垃圾食品。我心想，我有三个男孩住在这里，实际上是四个。总之，嗯，阿尔，天哪，我们可以和你聊个没完。就像和老朋友在一起。好吧，这确实是和老朋友在一起。我们真的很感谢你的时间。拿上这个。我之后要去。见到你真是太酷了，阿尔。阿尔，你是最棒的。
Thank you for doing this. Yeah, you are the best. You're legend. I mean, Sean, I even got you into this thing. I was, I was, I was worried. I was concerned. I don't know how much you liked sports. Sean's become a huge football fan. You should know. Yeah. I'm a big football fan. He and Scotty are watching football every weekend. Yeah. But, but I, I, it's an honor to meet you. I mean, there's no one bigger in the, in your field. Let me get your question on this. And if it's too controversial, we can cut it. You can tell us, but it's talking about the Reds and we've got all this gambling now that has become legalized, right? In fact, they're even making you guys give plugs to,
谢谢你做这件事。是的，你是最棒的。你是传奇。我是说，肖恩，我甚至把你带进了这件事。我，我，我担心。我很关心。我不知道你有多喜欢体育。肖恩已经成了橄榄球的超级粉丝。你应该知道。是的。我是橄榄球的超级粉丝。他和斯科蒂每个周末都在看橄榄球。是的。但是，但是，我，见到你真是荣幸。我是说，在你的领域里没有比你更大牌的人了。让我问你一个关于这个的问题。如果太有争议，我们可以剪掉。你可以告诉我们，但这是关于红人队的，我们现在有了所有这些已经合法化的赌博，对吧？事实上，他们甚至让你们这些家伙为
you know, the draft kings and all this other stuff on, on area. You're telling these guys to go ahead and gamble. Now that gambling is kind of a partner of professional sports, do you see any path to Pete Rose finally being led into the hall of fame with a little bit of a sort of a, well, I guess the, the past gambling is not that big of a deal anymore. Where, where do you stand on that? Does he have your vote? It's such an interesting question. I mean, now that you say that, I look at it this way. Then I saw Pete for three years, every at bat have known him for years, but he did. I mean, he broke a record that couldn't have been broken. In my mind, he's in my
你知道，DraftKings和所有其他东西做广告。你告诉这些家伙去赌博。现在赌博已经成为职业体育的合作伙伴，你认为皮特·罗斯（Pete Rose）最终进入名人堂有什么途径吗？有一点，嗯，我想，过去的赌博不再是什么大不了的事了。你对此持什么立场？他有你的投票吗？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我是说，既然你这么说，我是这样看的。然后我看了皮特三年，每一次击球，认识他多年，但他确实。我是说，他打破了一个不可能被打破的纪录。在我看来，他在我的
hall of fame. Yeah. Let's put it that way. I mean, he's one of the greatest players of all time. So I know there is a real hall of fame and then there's the hall of fame of your mind. And I don't know if he ever gets to the one in Cooper's town. I, you know, it's, people say it's tragic. It's not tragic. It's sad. It's just a sad situation. Yeah. And will Pete ever get in, you know, I don't, I don't know, but I'm afraid that if he does, it's going to be posthumously to put them in. These things will change. The more raised will be different. They've started to become different right now. But you know, to me, if I'm as a fan, who's in your hall of fame, he's in mine for sure. Yeah. Just be based on what you did when you were there, when you were playing.
名人堂里。是的。我们就这么说吧。我是说，他是有史以来最伟大的球员之一。所以我知道有一个真正的名人堂，然后是你心中的名人堂。我不知道他是否能进入库珀斯敦（Cooperstown）的那个。我，你知道，人们说这很悲剧。这不是悲剧。这很可悲。这只是一个可悲的情况。是的。皮特会进去吗，你知道，我，我不知道，但我担心如果他进去了，那将是死后才让他进去。这些事情会改变。更多的规则会不同。他们现在已经开始变得不同了。但是你知道，对我来说，如果我是作为一个球迷，谁在你的名人堂里，他肯定在我的名人堂里。是的。只是基于你在那里时，当你打球时所做的事情。
Did you, did you have that record? Yeah, you did. Did you do the great, you know, incredible thing? Yeah, you did. Okay, great. And that's what he should be on. And that's why other players are not because of stuff that they did while they were playing that affected their play. And we don't want to get into that. But there's also like, we don't want to get into this either. There's a lot worse crimes that we can all think of that would, you know, justify that. He's talking about murder, Sean. Fuck you. Here he goes with murder again. Yeah. It's such a bad rap. God, he just loves getting into murder. Al, big, huge thank you. Thank you, Al. And I mean, we could do a two-parter on this.
你有那个纪录吗？是的，你有。你做了伟大的，你知道，不可思议的事情吗？是的，你做了。好吧，太棒了。这就是他应该在的原因，而其他球员不在是因为他们在打球时所做的事情影响了他们的比赛。我们不想深入讨论那个。但也有像，我们也不想深入讨论这个。还有很多更糟糕的罪行，我们都能想到，这会，你知道，证明那是合理的。他在谈论谋杀，肖恩。去你的。他又开始谈论谋杀了。是的。这真是个坏名声。天哪，他就是喜欢谈论谋杀。阿尔，非常非常感谢。谢谢你，阿尔。我是说，我们可以做两部分。
I know we could. We're going to have you back at some point, Al. You're the greatest. The greatest of all time. Al Michaels. G-O-A-T. We're back on Thursday. I'll see you guys there. Okay. On to Bel Air now, right? Yes, sir. Let's do it. I love it, guys. I love it. And by the way, I'm going to, I'm spending the rest of the day, I'm going over and rifling Jimmy Burroughs' mailbox. Yeah. Get us some. Spare us some. Yeah. All right. Thanks, Al. Have a great day. Have a good day, guys. Bye. Bye-bye. That was really interesting. I mean, the greatest. I mean, are you as calm, settled, and comforted by his voice as I am? Yeah. I was going to say, sitting here, just listening to him tell a story, you're like, you just sort of think,
我知道我们可以。我们会在某个时候让你回来，阿尔。你是最棒的。有史以来最棒的。阿尔·迈克尔斯。G-O-A-T（史上最佳）。我们周四回来。到时候见。好的。现在去贝莱尔（Bel Air）了，对吧？是的，先生。我们做吧。我喜欢，伙计们。我喜欢。顺便说一下，我要，我花了一天剩下的时间，我要去翻吉米·伯罗斯（Jimmy Burrows）的邮箱。是的。给我们留点。给我们留点。是的。好的。谢谢，阿尔。祝你有美好的一天。祝你们有美好的一天，伙计们。再见。再见。那真的很有趣。我是说，最棒的。我是说，你像我一样被他的声音所平静、安抚和安慰吗？是的。我正想说，坐在这里，听他讲故事，你就像，你只是觉得，
come on, just keep talking, Al. I just want to hear you talk. But like, I touched on it before. It's like he's a savant. Like it's crazy. So then he goes, he goes like, you know, June 1994, he's making a date and I was thinking, and he goes, yeah, and I didn't want to embarrass because he was like, June 94, I was in LA because that was the same month that OJ went on that crazy ride in this Bronco. Oh my God. And I was here staying at my friend Rob's place and that was also the Knicks were in the playoffs and the Rangers won after 40-year drought in June 94, the Stanley Cup. That's all that shit came into my head. I think it was 95. Well, there's a pill for that guy. I'm just elevate your feet. Lay back flat. It's like I'm doing, it's like I'm
来吧，继续说，阿尔。我只想听你说话。但就像我之前提到的。他就像个天才。这太疯狂了。然后他说，他说，你知道，1994年6月，他在约会，我在想，他说，是的，我不想尴尬，因为他当时说，94年6月，我在洛杉矶，因为那是OJ在那辆野马车上进行那场疯狂逃亡的同一个月。哦天哪。我当时住在我朋友罗布家，那也是尼克斯队在季后赛，游骑兵队在40年干旱后赢得了94年6月的斯坦利杯。所有这些狗屎都涌进了我的脑海。我想那是95年。好吧，那家伙有药。我只是抬高你的脚。平躺着。就像我在做，就像我在
living in Bradley's movie. What was the movie? Limitless. Limitless, but I don't have to take the pill. You know what I mean? Right. No, I know. You're already broken. So wait. So, but, but I can't believe how long Al Michaels has been doing it and still is doing it and like. At the top of it. At the top of it. Yes. For how many decades? That's crazy. And not sick of it. Like he's like, yeah, let's go. Let's go. Like every week. How many shows do you think he does a week? Uh, shows. Like, well, I mean, well, he's got the matinee, right, Sean? He does. He does. Well, now he does in football and his regular skating. Now he's moved over. He does 17. Does he, or do they do 18 on, on Amazon? I think they do one a week, don't they? Anyway. Yeah. But I think
生活在布莱德利的电影里。那部电影叫什么？《永无止境》（Limitless）。《永无止境》，但我不需要吃药。你知道我的意思吗？对。不，我知道。你已经坏了。所以等等。所以，但是，我不敢相信阿尔·迈克尔斯做了这么久，现在还在做，而且像。在顶峰。在顶峰。是的。多少十年了？这太疯狂了。而且没厌倦。就像他，是的，走吧。走吧。就像每周一样。你认为他一周做多少节目？嗯，节目。就像，好吧，我是说，好吧，他有日场，对吧，肖恩？他有。他有。好吧，现在他在橄榄球和常规滑冰方面。现在他转过来了。他做17场。他做吗，还是他们在亚马逊上做18场？我想他们一周做一场，不是吗？总之。是的。但我认为
that the last week or two, they know. Anyway, he could do, he could do three a day. I mean, he's, yeah, nothing slowing him down. We played, we played this golf tourney last week, short for tournament and we, he and I, yeah, yeah. And, um, I got to play with Al and, uh, our buddy, uh, Skip Bronson, who's getting another mention on the podcast. This guy, Jason, and, and Coke Rack is a great guy and it hits the ball a million miles. But Al is the guy that everybody wants to see. And he were out there walking the course and everybody, and, and you just realize everybody, man, woman, child, grandpa, everybody, everybody wants to talk to Al Michaels cause he's been in their homes their whole life. He's been your tour guide for some
过去一两周，他们知道。总之，他可以一天做三场。我是说，他，是的，没什么能让他慢下来。我们上周打了这个高尔夫锦标赛，锦标赛的简称，他和我也，是的，是的。而且，嗯，我有幸和阿尔一起打球，还有，我们的伙伴，斯基普·布朗森（Skip Bronson），他在播客中又被提到了。这个家伙，杰森，还有可乐架（Coke Rack）是个很棒的家伙，球打得有一百万英里远。但阿尔是每个人都想见的人。我们走在球场上，每个人，男人、女人、孩子、爷爷，每个人，每个人都想和阿尔·迈克尔斯说话，因为他一生都在他们的家里。他是你一些
of your favorite moments. He does. And Jason, you enjoy the tour guide for stuff. You said that. You said, when you hear his voice, it's like, yeah, it's like warm and cozy and it's like, you're being a kid. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's great. Yeah. You know, I think, I think, like you said, you can hear him do anything. He's such a icon. Here comes. It's just that anything. He's back into one right now. Yeah. Go ahead. Well, I got one. I wish somebody would play him once and like, and like some like movie. Yeah. And what would, you know, those movies that are like, you know, when they play somebody famous, they're called like, what are they called? Autobiography films kind of. You just hijacked my vibe for that.
最喜欢时刻的导游。他确实。而且杰森，你喜欢这些东西的导游。你这么说过。你说过，当你听到他的声音时，就像，是的，就像温暖舒适，就像你还是个孩子。是的。是的。是的。太棒了。是的。你知道，我想，我想，就像你说的，你可以听他做任何事。他真是个偶像。来了。就是那个任何事。他现在又回到了一个。是的。继续。好吧，我有一个。我希望有人能让他演一次，就像，就像某部电影。是的。那会是什么，你知道，那些电影，就像，你知道，当他们扮演某个名人时，他们叫什么，你知道，他们叫什么？自传电影之类的。你刚才劫持了我的氛围。
Wait, no, no, no. What was it? No, no, no. Let's hear yours. Let's hear yours. I just think you would, you'd want, you'd listen to anything that was narrated. Bye. Pretty decent. Pretty decent. I think there's a way we can combine those. Oh, nice. Combine. Maybe there's a way to combine those. There's a way to combine. See, again, I go up and I put, I put my body in a vice. Why do I have to go up high? Because that's a people, that's how you say it. You accused us of doing it. Now you're doing it because it's natural. It's natural. It's just what people do. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry,
等等，不，不，不。那是什么？不，不，不。让我们听听你的。让我们听听你的。我只是觉得你会，你会听任何叙述的东西。再见。相当不错。相当不错。我想我们可以把它们结合起来。哦，不错。结合。也许有一种方法可以把它们结合起来。有一种方法可以结合。看，我又上去了，我把我的身体放进了一个虎钳里。为什么我必须往高处走？因为那是人们，这就是你说的。你指责我们这样做。现在你正在做，因为它是自然的。它是自然的。这就是人们所做的。SmartLess是100%有机的，由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）手工制作，
and Rob Armjurf. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和罗布·阿姆杰夫（Rob Armjurf）。SmartLess。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus提前且无广告地收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。